I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hi there. Do you have your drink ready? Did you pour a drink? Because today we're talking about cocktails. I should have. Dang it. Why are we not drinking right now? That's a whole other podcast. But you know what? With all of the kids like virtual learning, it might have to happen. Angela, do you want to tell everyone where you are
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来精彩的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。你们好。你们准备好饮料了吗？倒了饮料吗？因为今天我们要聊鸡尾酒。我本来应该倒的。见鬼。我们现在为什么不喝酒？那是另一个播客要聊的。但你知道吗？所有的孩子都在上网课，这可能真的得发生。安吉拉，你想告诉大家你在哪里
right now? Yes, you guys. Okay. So the internet at my house is El Kravsky. And can I say El Kravsky? That's so weird. I think you can. We've said worse. So the internet at my house is really bad. And apparently we're in an area that doesn't even qualify for a real upgrade. Like we've called and they're like, yeah, no, it's not available there. And I'm like, what are you talking about? So anyway, I just, well, I just did not have a great system. I tried Jenna. I really tried for months, for months. Yeah. And what you guys haven't seen is I would just be zooming with Jenna and then I just get the boot for like 45 minutes. Yeah. And then people are always like, why don't you guys just do a video version of
现在吗？是的，大家。好吧。所以我们家的网络简直烂透了。我能说烂透了这词吗？太怪了。我想你可以。我们说过更难听的。所以我们家的网络真的很差。显然我们处于一个甚至连真正的宽带升级都不符合资格的地区，就像我们打过电话，他们说，是的，不行，那里没法升级。我说，你在说什么呢？所以总之，我只是，好吧，我真的没有一个好系统。我试过了，珍娜。我真的试了好几个月，好几个月。是的。你们没看到的是，我本来在跟珍娜视频，然后我就会被踢出去大约45分钟。是的。然后大家总是问，为什么你们不做个视频版的
your podcast? Just throw it on up there. And I'm like, well, if you want to see 45 minutes of Angela cursing and disappearing and coming back, we're happy to throw it on up for you. Sam said his favorite was when Mindy was a guest. I got booted off three times and he said he could hear on my audio track. You and Mindy were talking and I was just going, mother. So, yes. But also, Angela, you would be frozen and then Mindy and I wouldn't really know if you were there or not. And so we would throw to you. We'd be like, right, Ange? Oh, I don't think she's there. No, she's not. She's not responding. She's not moving. So I am really excited. Very COVID safely. Thank you to the folks at Ear Wolf today. I guess
播客呢？直接放上去啊。我说，好吧，如果你想看安吉拉骂脏话、消失又出现的45分钟视频，我们很乐意为你放上去。萨姆说他最喜欢的一期是敏迪当嘉宾的那次。我被踢出去三次，他说他能在我的音轨里听到。你和敏迪在说话，而我一直在喊，妈的。所以，是的。不过还有，安吉拉，你会画面卡住，然后敏迪和我其实都不知道你在不在。所以我们会把话抛给你。我们会说，对吧，安吉？哦，我觉得她不在。不，她不在。她没反应。她没动。所以我是真的很兴奋。非常符合疫情防控安全。感谢今天耳狼的伙伴们。我猜
at Ear Wolf is just me in one room, Sam in another room. And I guess Conan O'Brien is coming later. Oh, he canceled. So it's just me and Sam. It's just me and Sam here today. And when I saw Sam, I thought I was going to cry because it was just so fun to see him in person rather than just hearing him. Well, it's really cool for me to see you in the studio. It's making me very homesick. I know. And then I have my mask and we have sanitizer and you guys, we're figuring it out. We're figuring it out how to safely return to work. And that gives me hope. Yeah. And I know a lot of you all out there are doing this. I know my sister, you know, my sister's a nurse and one of my sisters works
在耳狼只有我一个房间，萨姆在另一个房间。我猜柯南·奥布莱恩一会儿要来。哦，他取消了。所以今天只有我和萨姆。今天这里只有我和萨姆。当我看到萨姆时，我以为自己要哭了，因为亲眼见到他而不是只听到声音实在是太有趣了。嗯，对我来说在录音室里见到你真的很酷。这让我非常想念大家。我懂。然后我戴着口罩，我们有洗手液，大家，我们正在适应。我们正在摸索如何安全地重返工作岗位。这给了我希望。是的。我知道你们外面有很多人也在这样做。我知道我姐姐，你知道，我姐姐是个护士，我其中一个姐姐在
for the phone company and she gave me a real lecture on Wi-Fi and what I apparently don't have. You guys, there's this thing. It's like the holy grail of Wi-Fi. Jenna, I think you know what it's called. It's like gamer Wi-Fi. Yeah, you get a gamer modem and it can just handle a lot. And we got it because, you know, we're trying to make a podcast while both of my kids are zooming school. So to have three of us on the system, the guy came by to install it. And he had this little like thing that shows you the strength of your signal. He looked at my husband and he goes, you guys really don't get much of a signal here. And we're like, yeah, we know. We're aware. It's why you're here. At least it's available in
电话公司工作，她给我上了一堂关于无线网络以及我显然没有的东西的长课。大家，有个东西。就像是无线网络的圣杯。珍娜，我想你知道它叫什么。就像是游戏玩家专用无线网络。对，你弄个游戏专用的调制解调器，它就能处理很多数据。我们弄了这个，因为，你知道，我们试图在一边制作播客的同时，我的两个孩子还要上网课。为了让三个人同时用这个系统，有个家伙过来安装。他有个小东西能显示信号强度。他看了看我丈夫说，你们这信号真的好不到哪去。我们就说，对，我们知道。我们心里有数。这就是你为什么会在这的原因。至少这在
your area, Jenna. It's available in our area. Well, now we need to get you gamer headphones and we need to get you a gamer chair. Have you seen? They have these special gamer chairs. Oh, it would make me really happy to see you sitting in one. Are we ever going to talk about the episode today? I don't know. Oh, God, yes, maybe we shouldn't. What are we here for? Oh my gosh, 20 minutes later. It is cocktails, you guys. Season three, episode 17. It is written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by J. J. Abrams. Here's a quick summary. Michael and Jan go public with their relationship when they attend a party at David Wallace's home. The CFO, not his initials, common mistake. Everyone else in the office
你们这有，珍娜。我们这有。好吧，现在我们需要给你买游戏玩家耳机，还需要给你买一把游戏玩家椅子。你见识过吗？他们有这种特殊的电竞椅。哦，看到你坐在上面会让我非常开心。我们到底什么时候才能聊聊今天的剧集？不知道。哦，天哪，是的，也许我们不该聊。我们到底是来干嘛的？哦天哪，20分钟后。是鸡尾酒，各位。第三季，第17集。由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，J·J·艾布拉姆斯执导。以下是简短总结。迈克尔和简在大卫·华莱士家参加派对时公开了他们的恋情。首席财务官，不是他的名字缩写，常见错误。办公室里的其他人
goes out for happy hour. And Pam tells Roy about her and Jim. Oh, Pam, Pam, not Pammy, but Pam. Don't call me Pammy. Don't call her Pammy. I bet you have some fast facts. Fast fact number one. This is a fan question from Scott F. Eladio Ben and Abby Kellner. How was J. J. Abrams tapped to direct? Right? J. J. Abrams directed this. Freakin' Abrams. You guys Google him. He's done everything. We could not believe he was coming to our little show. Now, this was before he directed Star Wars, but Angela, still. Still? Does it freak you out that Star Wars guy directed you in an episode of The Office? J. J., I know you probably listened to our podcast. Faithfully, why wasn't there a very tiny, petite, sassy
出去喝欢乐时光。帕姆告诉罗伊她和吉姆的事。哦，帕姆，帕姆，不是小帕姆，而是帕姆。别叫我小帕姆。别叫她小帕姆。我打赌你有一些快讯。快讯一。这是一个来自F.埃拉迪奥·本和艾比·凯尔纳的粉丝提问。J·J·艾布拉姆斯是怎么被邀请来执导的？对吧？J·J·艾布拉姆斯执导的这集。该死的艾布拉姆斯。你们去谷歌一下他。他什么都做过。我们简直不敢相信他会来我们的这个小节目。现在，这是在他执导《星球大战》之前，但是安吉拉，依然很震惊。依然很震惊？《星球大战》的导演导了你演的一集《办公室》，你不觉得毛骨悚然吗？J·J，我知道你可能在听我们的播客。
blonde in your Star Wars movie? Please, just in the background. I don't even have to say anything. Please, can I just be an extra in a Star Wars movie? Please. Yeah. I'll just walk by. And she'll just walk by. She won't do anything but just walk by. I promise. A tiny, blonde comedian is just going to walk on through Star Wars, J. J. No shenanigans. I won't look at camera. I'll look just straight at the ground. I hope, I hope he hears this. Well, listen, guys. So at this point, J. J. Abrams was most famous for the TV shows Lost and Alias Felicity. Felicity. He did Felicity, too. Yes. Wow. I know. That wasn't in my notes. Well, I think it was just because I was such a huge fan of Lost and Alias, the
忠实地听，为什么你的《星球大战》电影里没有一个非常娇小、俏皮的金发女郎？求你了，哪怕就在背景里。我甚至都不用说什么。求你了，我能去《星球大战》电影里跑个龙套吗？求你了。好啦。我就是走过去。她就会走过去。她什么都不做，就是走过去。我保证。一个娇小的金发喜剧演员就要大摇大摆地走进《星球大战》了，J·J。没有恶作剧。我不会看镜头的。我只盯着地面看。我希望，我希望他能听到这个。好吧，听着，伙计们。所以在那个时候，J·J·艾布拉姆斯最著名的作品是电视剧《迷失》和《双面女间谍》、《费莉希蒂》。《费莉希蒂》。他也导演了《费莉希蒂》。是的。哇。我知道。那不在我的笔记里。好吧，我想那只是因为我是《迷失》和《双面女间谍》的超级粉丝，
role you didn't get. Thanks for reminding me. I have to tell you, oh my God, this made me laugh so hard. You posted about the Ben Franklin episode and you were like on your Instagram, you're like, and you know, also we talk about the fact that I didn't get the part of Sydney and Alias. Jennifer Gardner went away in and I responded, did you see her post from the beach? Did you see her try to ride that skimmer thing? I mean, come on, lady. I can't believe you are doubling down on this. I did one hour of yoga today very easily. Well, I'll have you know, which basically qualifies me to play a spy on television. Look out community of secrets. Okay, okay. In case you're wondering, I did not confront
你没得到那个角色。谢谢你提醒我。我得告诉你，哦天哪，这把我笑死了。你发了关于本·富兰克林那一集的动态，你在Instagram上发文说，你知道，我们还聊到我没有得到《双面女间谍》里悉尼这个角色。珍妮佛·加纳去了，我回复道，你看到她在海滩上的动态了吗？你看到她尝试骑那个水上滑板了吗？我是说，拜托，女士。我真不敢相信你还在固执己见。我今天非常轻松地做了一小时瑜伽。好吧，我要告诉你的是，这基本上让我有资格在电视上扮演间谍了。小心了，秘密社团。好吧，好吧。如果你想知道的话，我没有质问
J. J. Abrams about why I did not receive the role of Sydney Bristow. Opportunity missed. I let it go. But here's the thing. Here's what happened, guys. He reached out to us about directing an episode and we were like, yeah. And we were like, come direct an episode. That's how it happened. We were so giddy, Jenna. We were all so excited. I just remember him being so smiley. Remember how much he smiled? He was like so happy and kind and just energetic. He was so nice. And then like, I don't know, a few months later, I ran into JJ and his wife at like a fancy, you know, a word show party. And he was like, Angela and like chatted me up and she was so nice. They're just really nice folks, y'all. Yeah.
J·J·艾布拉姆斯我为什么没有得到悉尼·布里斯托这个角色。错失良机。我放下了。但事实是这样的。事情是这样的，伙计们。他主动联系我们说要导演一集，我们就说，好啊。我们就说，来导演一集吧。事情就是这样发生的。我们当时太晕头转向了，珍娜。我们都太兴奋了。我只记得他一直在笑。还记得他笑得有多开心吗？他那么开心、友善，而且充满活力。他太好了。然后就像，我不知道，几个月后，我在某个高级的，你知道的，颁奖派对上遇到了JJ和他的妻子。他说，安吉拉，然后跟我聊了聊，她人也太好了。他们真的是很好的人，各位。是的。
It's all true. So put me in your stinkin' Star Wars movie, JJ. Yeah, she just wants to walk by. I just want to walk on. All right. Fastback number two, lady. I'm calling this one, Location Change. Why are you saying it like that? I don't know. Is it intriguing? Location Change. Yeah. Yeah, I'm intrigued. All right, good. Fan question from Anna Carter, Steve Smith, Sophia B, Chelsea Lane and Berkeley S. What house was used as David Wallace's home in this episode? Was it the same house used for the inside and the outside? And then we've got additional questions from Mary Roberts, Kelsey Joseph, Zhu Yi Wang, Kendall Kay and Yvonne A. Hold up. David Wallace's house is a different house than the one used in branch
千真万确。所以把我塞进你那该死的《星球大战》电影里吧，JJ。是的，她只想走过去。我只想走进去。好的。快讯二，女士。我把这个叫做，地点变更。你为什么那样说？不知道。这不是很吸引人吗？地点变更。对。是的，我很感兴趣。很好，很好。来自安娜·卡特、史蒂夫·史密斯、索菲亚·B、切尔西·莱恩和伯克利·S的粉丝提问。这一集里用了哪栋房子作为大卫·华莱士的家？室内和室外用的是同一栋房子吗？然后我们还有来自玛丽·罗伯茨、凯尔西·约瑟夫、朱一王、肯道尔·K和伊冯娜·A的额外提问。等一下。大卫·华莱士的房子跟用来拍分公司
closing. But some of the details are the same. What gives? Here is the answer. Yes, guys, these are good questions because the original house that you saw in branch closing was in Pasadena. This is a different house. This one is in Encino. More people wrote in about the house too. And many people noted that this house has a circular driveway in the front, which is different. We changed the house because J.J. Abrams really liked the interior of this house. So we did dress the front door to match the front door of the Pasadena house. But yeah, it was a different house. Good eye. Very good catch, folks. Real good catch. And that makes sense because he would need the interior of the house more
倒闭的那栋房子不是同一栋。但有些细节是一样的。怎么回事？答案是这样的。是的，伙计们，这些都是好问题，因为你在分公司倒闭里看到的原本那栋房子在帕萨迪纳。这是一栋不同的房子。这栋在恩西诺。还有更多人写信问关于房子的事。许多人指出这栋房子的前面有一个环形车道，这很不一样。我们换了房子，因为J·J·艾布拉姆斯真的很喜欢这栋房子的室内。所以我们确实把前门装修得跟帕萨迪纳房子的前门一样。但是的，这是另一栋房子。好眼力。大家抓得真准。抓得太准了。这就说得通了，因为他需要房子的室内比
than the exterior because the whole episode almost happens in that house. Yeah, and it needed to flow. And there's a lot of moments in this episode where you're on one group of people and then the camera will rack focus and then some other thing is happening in the background. So having that open floor plan inside was really important to the storytelling. I agree. All right. So my next little piece of this fast fact is about poor Richards. We shot poor Richards at the Pickwick Pub, which is inside the Pickwick Bowling Alley in Burbank, California, which is right next to the Pickwick Ice Rink where we shot Michael's birthday. Well, I have a question for you about this because if memory serves, we shot
室外更多，因为整集几乎都发生在那栋房子里。是的，而且需要流畅。这一集中有很多时刻，你先关注一组人，然后镜头会变焦，背景里就会发生其他事情。所以里面那种开放式的户型对于讲故事非常重要。我同意。好的。所以这个快讯的下一小部分是关于穷理查的。我们在加州伯班克的皮克威克保龄球馆里面的皮克威克酒吧拍摄了穷理查的戏，它就在我们拍迈克尔生日那个皮克威克溜冰场的旁边。嗯，我对此有个问题，因为如果我没记错的话，我们拍
the interior stuff at Pickwick, but that exterior parking lot was a different location. Yes. And it was the bar. What's it called? The bar at Oyster House on Moorpark in Studio City. Great catch, lady. Yes. Yes, lady. I knew what parking lot that was because back in yielding improv days, when I was performing long farm improv, sometimes we would go there afterwards for a drink to celebrate our show. So the actual bar that's inside of that parking lot area is called Oyster Bar. It's called the bar at Oyster House. Oh, I've never been. And you can enter from the parking lot, which is how we sort of set it up, right? Or you can enter from the street. Just so you know. Now, I have a quick question for you because
内景是在皮克威克，但那个外景停车场是另一个地方。是的。那是那个酒吧。叫什么来着？伯班克市中心莫尔帕克的生蚝屋酒吧。抓得真准，女士。是的。是的，女士。我知道那是哪个停车场，因为在以前玩即兴表演的日子里，当我表演长篇即兴喜剧时，有时我们之后会去那里喝一杯来庆祝演出成功。所以停车场区域里面的那个酒吧实际叫生蚝酒吧。它叫生蚝屋酒吧。哦，我从来没去过。你可以从停车场进去，我们大概就是这么设计的，对吧？或者你可以从街上进去。顺便告诉你们。现在，我有个简单的问题要问你，因为
I know we're going to talk more about Poor Richards later. Have you been to the real Poor Richards in Scranton, Angela? Yes. And do you enter from a parking lot? Yes. And was it a good match? Sort of. Oh, I cannot wait to hear more. Save it. Okay, I'll save it. I'll save it. I'll save it. All right, I'm going to move us on to Fast Effect number three. Lady. What? Do you remember during Ben Franklin, when we said that the SAG nominating guy came to set to tell us that we were all nominated for SAG awards? Yeah. Well, we shot this episode right after we won our SAG award. Oh my gosh. Oh, dang it. Dang it. I should have looked at my journal. I bet I wrote about it. I wrote about it in my journal. Dang
我知道我们等会儿会详细聊穷理查。安吉拉，你去过斯克兰顿真正的穷理查吗？去过。你是从停车场进去的吗？是的。那还原度高吗？有点像。哦，我都迫不及待想听更多了。留着吧。好吧，我留着。我留着。我留着。好吧，我要进入快讯三了。女士。什么？还记得在拍本·富兰克林那一集时，我们说美国演员工会奖的提名人来到片场告诉我们所有人都获得了演员工会奖提名吗？对。我们拍这一集的时候，正好是我们赢得演员工会奖之后不久。天哪。哦，见鬼。见鬼。我本该看看我的日记。我打赌我写下来了。我在日记里写了。见鬼
it. Okay, would you write? Okay, here's what I wrote. We won the SAG award for best comedic ensemble cast. Our table was right next to the people from 24. So yes, I was drooling all night. What is that? Why am I saying that? Lady, we were such dorks. What a great group of people. I talked to Kiefer. Or should I say babbled? That's what I wrote. Later that night, I met Patrick Dempsey. Oh my God. Right? He has magic sparkles that rotate around his head. The word dreamy is completely accurate. Jenna, I don't know what happens to the two of us, but when we write in our journals, it's like a 13-year-old girl is writing in sparkly pencil. You know? 100%. What is this? I was a grown woman when I wrote this. I know.
好吧，你写了什么？好吧，我是这么写的。我们赢得了最佳喜剧群演奖的演员工会奖。我们的桌子紧挨着《24小时》剧组的人。所以没错，我整晚都在流口水。那是什么？我为什么这么说？女士，我们当时太书呆子了。多么棒的一群人啊。我跟基弗聊了。或者我该说结巴了？这就是我写的。那天晚礼服，我遇到了帕特里克·德姆西。哦，天哪。对吧？他头周围旋转着魔法火花。梦幻这个词完全准确。珍娜，我不知道我们俩怎么了，但当我们写日记时，就像一个13岁的小女孩在用亮晶晶的铅笔写字。你知道吗？百分之百。这是什么？我写这篇日记时已经是个成年女性了。我知道。
All right. Then I wrote, the best part of the night was probably when Oscar, David, Angela, Kate, and her boyfriend and I all started dancing in the middle of a party that did not have a dance floor. That sounds like us. That does. But we started a craze and soon a bunch of people were all going to town. I think that's the night I was doing like a really kind of rock and roll version of the Charleston with Jack McBrayer and I stepped back right onto Oscar's date's foot. Oh, remember that? I felt so bad. Now, this isn't the night that you jumped into the pool with your dress on, is it? That's later. No, that's a different night. We'll get to that, guys. Always wanted to do it. People had jumped in a pool in their
好吧。然后我写道，当晚最棒的部分可能就是当奥斯卡、大卫、安吉拉、凯特、她的男友和我开始在一个没有舞池的派对中央跳舞的时候。听起来很像我们。确实是。但我们掀起了一股风潮，很快一大群人都开始嗨起来。我想那是那天晚上我跟杰克·麦克布瑞尔跳了一种非常摇滚风格的查尔斯顿舞，然后我一脚踩在了奥斯卡女伴的脚上。哦，还记得那个吗？我感觉太糟糕了。对了，这不是你穿着礼服跳进泳池的那天晚上吧，对吧？那是后来的事。不，那是另一个晚上。我们会聊到那点的，伙计们。一直都想这么做。人们曾穿着他们华丽的
fancy dresses. Remember Angelina Jolie did this one time? Look, she wasn't at this party. But I was determined to do this once in my life. I regret not doing it. I'll tell you, the car ride home sucked. But the first part was magical. All right, guys, well, we're going to take a break and we will be back to break down this episode. Cocktails. Yeah. All right, you guys, we are back. Now, before I break down the cold open for you, I have a few observations to share with you that I remember. Number one, Steve was sick. Do you remember, Jenna? Really? Yes, I don't. He had like a cold bug this week. And you can hear it. You can hear it if you rewatch. So he really had to power through because there were a few scenes he was not
礼服跳进泳池。还记得安吉丽娜·朱莉有一次就这样做过吗？听着，她可没参加这个派对。但我决心这辈子一定要做一次。我很后悔没这么做。我跟你说，回家的车程糟糕透了。但前半部分简直是魔幻的。好吧，伙计们，我们要休息一下，一会儿回来继续剖析这一集。鸡尾酒。是的。好的，伙计们，我们回来了。现在，在我为你们剖析开场白之前，我有一些自己记得的观察结果要与大家分享。第一，史蒂夫生病了。你还记得吗，珍娜？真的吗？是的，我不记得。他这周得了感冒。你能听出来。如果你重看的话能听出来。所以他真的只能咬牙坚持，因为有几场戏他感觉
feeling well in. And no Phyllis. No Phyllis. Phyllis is on her honeymoon. Oh, yes. Yeah. So no Phyllis. And then before we get into the cold open, the blooper reel that's online for this episode is fantastic. My daughter loved it. We watched it over and over. And now I can see these moments where people were breaking. I'm going to point them out as we go. Okay. Oh, I love that. All right. So in this cold open, Michael is going to show off his magic skills. You know, he's been in magic camp and he has a straight jacket on Dwight is securing chains around him. He's going to lock it up and then show everyone how he can be a Houdini and get out of it. Yes. Well, we had a fan question about this Ange. Megan Keele, Rhiannon Cobb,
很不舒服。而且没有菲利斯。没有菲利斯。菲利斯在度蜜月。哦，对。是的。所以没有菲利斯。然后在我们进入开场白之前，这一集在网上发布的NG花絮剪辑太棒了。我女儿很喜欢。我们看了又看。现在我能看出大家笑场的那几个瞬间。我会在我们往下看时指出来。好的。哦，我太喜欢了。好的，所以在这一集的开场白中，迈克尔要展示他的魔术技巧。你知道，他去参加过魔术夏令营，他穿着一件束缚衣，德怀特正在用铁链把他绑起来。他要把自己锁起来，然后向大家展示他如何能像胡迪尼一样挣脱出来。是的。我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问，安吉。梅根·基尔、里安农·科布、
Ellie Jo Higginbotham, Charlotte Nicholas, and Claire Nichols all asked how long did Steve have to be in that straight jacket? He spent the morning in that thing. Yeah. I asked Kent Zabornak about it because you know, he keeps all the logs from our production. Are you kidding me? That's how he tells me all this stuff, Angela. He has all of the call sheets and the production logs and all the he has it all on file. I knew he had a lot of information. I didn't realize he had like the production logs that show the time increments we spent on each scene. That is crazy. Yeah. He said that all told Steve was in the straight jacket for about an hour and a half. We didn't do that many takes. We did about seven or eight based on his records. But knowing now
艾莉·乔·希金伯顿、夏洛特·尼古拉斯和克莱尔·尼古拉斯都问史蒂夫在那个束缚衣里呆了多久？他在那个东西里度过了整个上午。是的。我问过肯·扎博纳克，因为你知道，他保留了我们所有的制作日志。你在开玩笑吧？他就是这么把这些事告诉我的，安吉拉。他保留了所有的通告单和制作日志，还有他把所有东西都存档了。我知道他有很多信息。我没想到他连记录我们在每个场景花时间的制作日志都有。太疯狂了。是的。他说总的来说，史蒂夫穿束缚衣大约有一个半小时。我们没有拍那么多条。根据他的记录，我们拍了七八条。但现在知道
that Steve was sick while he was rolling around on the ground trying to get out of that crazy outfit is, oh my gosh. Yeah. He was like flopping off the chair, like diving across the table, knocking a plant over. Well, here's my question. You know, you saw that he had the very, very large key in the corner of his mouth, right? So obviously, yes. That then falls on the ground and Jim steps on it with his foot. That was just step one. I mean, let's say he was able to get the key and undo the chains. How was he going to get out of the straight jacket? I don't know. But in the blooper reel in one take, Steve manages to get out of the straight jacket. No. Yes. And we all cheer. I remember shooting that. I know. It was like the same moment I remember when like
史蒂夫在地上打滚想摆脱那件疯狂的衣服时其实生着病，哦天哪。是的。他从椅子上摔下来，像潜水一样扑过桌子，撞翻了一株植物。好吧，我的问题是。你知道的，你看到他嘴角落里含着一把非常非常大的钥匙，对吧？所以显然是的。然后钥匙掉在地上了，吉姆用脚踩住了它。那只是第一步。我是说，假设他能够拿到钥匙并解开铁链。他要怎么从束缚衣里挣脱出来？我不知道。但在NG花絮里的一条里，史蒂夫设法从束缚衣里挣脱出来了。不会吧。是的。我们都欢呼了。我记得当时拍的情形。我知道。这就跟我记得的那个时刻一样，就像
in basketball when he actually made one of those crazy Hail Mary shots and we all cheered, but they can't use it. Yeah. Yeah. Well, lady, we also had a fan catch and I love this fan catch. It's from Stella P and Madison J. In the cold open, Jim says to Kevin, have a good weekend. It's Friday and no one is dressed for casual Friday. Oh, that's a very good catch. I bet that made you happy. They went on to say, isn't casual Friday supposed to exist until Toby cancels it in season five, episode 26? Wow. Applause. All right. So should we move on and get into this episode? Yes, let's do it. Michael and Dwight are getting ready to leave for this big party at David Wallace's house. He makes Dwight smell his breath. He just gets in there.
在篮球比赛中，当他真的投进那种疯狂的超远压哨球时，我们都欢呼了，但他们没法用那个镜头。是的。是的。好吧，女士，我们还有一个粉丝发现，我超级喜欢这个粉丝发现。它来自斯特拉·P和麦迪逊·J。在开场白中，吉姆对凯文说，祝你周末愉快。今天是星期五，而且没有人穿休闲星期五的衣服。哦，这抓得真准。我打赌这让你很高兴。他们接着说，休闲星期五不是应该一直存在，直到第五季第26集托比取消它吗？哇。掌声。好吧。那么我们应该继续往下看这一集吗？好的，我们开始吧。迈克尔和德怀特正准备动身去大卫·华莱士家的那个盛大派对。他让德怀特闻闻他的口气。他凑得真近。
It's like Steve's head is a Pez dispenser. He's crawling inside it. I don't know how they got through that. I know. And I love Dwight's line. He's like, good, not great. Yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah, okay. And then Michael has this talking head, you guys, where he really lays out the stakes of this episode for him. It is Jan and his coming out party, he said. They're, they're finally an official couple. This means a lot to him. Yeah. Yeah. And I have one thing. It's a blooper real catch of someone about to break. You guys, at three minutes, 15 seconds, Michael is trying to see if Jim wants to carpool. He leans down. He's like, you want a carpool? John could not get it together. John was laughing so hard. And Steve knew it. And Steve was messing with him. Steve at one point in
就像史蒂夫的头是个贝兹糖果盒。他整个人都快爬进去了。我不知道他们是怎么挺过那段的。我知道。我喜欢德怀特的台词。他说，很好，但算不上棒。是的。哦，好吧。是的，好吧。然后迈克尔有一段对着镜头的独白，伙计，他在这段独白里真正阐明了这一集对他的重要性。这是他和简的公开派对，他说。他们，他们终于正式成为情侣了。这对意义重大。是的。是的。我有一件事。这是一个关于某人快要笑场的NG花絮发现。伙计们，在3分15秒时，迈克尔想看看吉姆想不想拼车。他俯身。他说，你想拼车吗？约翰根本控制不住自己。约翰笑得太厉害了。史蒂夫知道。史蒂夫在逗他。史蒂夫在花絮里的某个时刻说，
the bloopers goes, you want to ride in my seabring? And you know he knew that was going to make John break. And John was like destroyed by it. Oh, I loved it whenever Steve would do that. And he would do it to John mostly because he would find some little thing. And it was usually when he would get like real, real close. Yeah. You want a carpool? Yeah. I want to ride my seabring. Yeah. It's really fun to watch. So now we cut to Michael and Dwight are in the car. And Dwight is like, thank you so much for bringing me along. And Michael's like, wait a second, should I have brought you along? I don't know. Yeah. And then Jan calls on speakerphone. And do we find out Michael's nickname for her in this? What does he call her? He says, Hello, Buttercup. Oh, is this a
你想坐我的赛百灵吗？你知道他知道那一定会让约翰笑场。而约翰被那句话击溃了。哦，我太喜欢史蒂夫这么做了。而且他大多时候都是对约翰这么干，因为他会找到一些小细节。而且通常都是当他靠得非常非常近的时候。是的。你想拼车吗？对。我想坐我的赛百灵。对。看这个真的太有趣了。所以现在镜头切到迈克尔和德怀特在车里。德怀特说，非常感谢你带上我。迈克尔说，等等，我刚才真该带上你吗？我不知道。是的。然后简用免提打电话，我们在这一集里知道迈克尔对她的昵称了吗？他叫她什么？他说，你好，小甜心。哦，这是
Princess Bride moment? It sounds like it a little bit. Well, Jan is like, what do you say we blow off this party? And we just like, we just go after each other like we did on that black sand beach in Jamaica. Yeah, doesn't she say something like why don't we just smash up on each other or something? It's a real visual image. I probably didn't need. And then she's like, wait, am I on speakerphone? Are the cameras there? And she's like, I'll just see you at the party. But Michael, Michael, it does not want to go get it on with Jan. He is like, no, I want to go to this party with you and show everyone that you and I are together. I know this kind of breaks my heart because it's clearly so important for him. And she just wants to blow it off. She doesn't want to go
《公主新娘》的时刻？听起来确实有点像。简说，你怎么看我们翘掉这个派对？我们就像在牙买加那片黑沙滩上一样，狠狠地缠绵。对啊，她是不是说为什么我们不互相猛烈撞击或者别的什么？这真是一个很形象的画面。我可能并不需要这个画面。然后她说，等等，我是开着免提吗？摄像机在那儿吗？然后她说，我会在派对上见你。但是迈克尔，迈克尔他才不想跟简亲热呢。他心想，不，我想和你一起去这个派对，向所有人证明你和我在一起。我知道这有点让人心碎，因为这对他来说显然太重要了。而简只想翘掉。她不想公开
public with him. And he's kind of forcing her hand. And Jan, I know you're a fictional character and you won't ever hear this, but I need to say it. Always assume you're on speakerphone and cameras are rolling. This is something that comes up with her all the time. She's like, are the cameras there? I'm like, why are you asking just give up? They're there. It's so true. Well, then Jenna, as they're off and on their way, we have at front reception, Roy and Pam. And Pam was like, Roy, come out with us tonight. And he's like, no, my brother took a bath on the jet skis. We're going to go get drunk. And you're like, yeah, we're going to a bar. We're going somewhere where that can happen. And you've got to do boyfriend stuff. If you want to be my boyfriend, right? You make a big speech.
跟他在一起。她有点在逼他就范。简，我知道你是一个虚构的角色，你永远不会听到这个，但我必须要说：永远假设自己开着免提，而且摄像机正在拍摄。这是她身上经常出现的问题。她总是问，摄像机在那儿吗？我就想，你为什么还要问，认输吧？它们就在那儿。太真实了。好了，珍娜，当他们动身出发时，我们在前台看到了罗伊和帕姆。帕姆说，罗伊，今晚跟我们一起出去吧。他说，不，我弟弟在水上摩托上亏惨了。我们要去喝个烂醉。然后你会觉得，对啊，我们要去酒吧。我们要去一个能发生这种事的地方。你得做个男朋友该做的事。如果你想做我男友的话，对吧？你发表了一大通演说。
Yeah. And Roy is like, okay. And it's kind of this nice moment where you see Pam as being more assertive and Roy hears her. Well, there's a deleted scene, Jenna, that would have happened right here that I thought was really sweet, where Roy notices your art has been framed and is hanging on the wall. And he compliments it. He's like, Hey, oh my God, it's your art. It's framed. You know, that's so cool. And it's the sweet moment that I think would have just extended that beat of where Roy, he's trying. Yeah. Before we move on from the sweet Pam Roy moment, there is a new plant alert. Another new plant at reception? I wish really and truly there was a way that someone could, by the end of the nine years, tell us how many plants that Pam had had.
对啊。然后罗伊说，好吧。这其实是一个挺美好的时刻，你看到帕姆变得更有主见了，而且罗伊听进去了。珍娜，其实这里本来有一个删减片段，我觉得非常温馨，那就是罗伊注意到你的画已经被装裱好挂在墙上了。他还夸奖了它。他说，嘿，天哪，这是你的画。装裱好了。你知道，这太酷了。这是一个很温馨的时刻，我觉得它本可以进一步延续那个桥段，展现罗伊他其实在努力。对啊。在我们离开这个温馨的帕姆和罗伊的时刻之前，又有新植物警告了。前台又多了一盆新植物？我真心希望有那么一天，在这九年结束时，有人能告诉我们帕姆一共养过多少盆植物。
There is a new plant. It's in a very cute blue ceramic pot with what looks like to be like little colorful balloons on the pot. Hmm. It's very cute. It won't last. It's very cute. My gosh, what is this like secret story we're telling about Pam's ability to care for house plants? Well, it's not a bunch of a story. You know, a friend of mine gave me an air plant recently. It lives on air. You like water it once a week. You, you turn it upside down and you put it in a glass of water and then you put it back in the pot. And you know what, Angela? It's dead. Well, it doesn't sound like a real thing. What? No, it's real. An air plant is real. It's a real thing. It was living in air. It's not even in any soil. What do you mean in air? What does that even look like?
确实有一盆新植物。它在一个非常可爱的蓝色陶瓷花盆里，花盆上似乎画着一些彩色的小气球。嗯。非常可爱。它活不久的。非常可爱。天哪，我们到底在讲关于帕姆照顾室内植物能力的什么秘密故事啊？好吧，这其实算不上什么故事。你知道，我朋友最近送了我一盆空气凤梨。它靠空气生存。你每周给它浇一次水。你把它倒过来放进一杯水里，然后再把它放回花盆里。你知道吗，安吉拉？它死了。听起来不像是真的。什么？不，它是真的。空气凤梨是真的。它是真实存在的。它靠空气生活。它甚至不在任何土壤里。你什么意思，在空气里？那到底长什么样？
It looks like a plant. It's in a piece of wood, but there's no soil or water in the pot. Okay. Okay. It's like a ferny kind of plant. Okay. And then you, the idea is that this is the thing that people who can't keep other plants alive can keep alive because it lives on air. I don't know. No, but mine is dead. Is it like a fancy chia pet? No, no. It's an air plant. It was an air plant. It was. Oh my gosh, you and Pam can't keep plants alive. We can't. Well, listen, Pam is now going to have her big moment in her talking head. All right, everyone. She is going to start being direct with people. She's going to start asking for what she wants. She says, look out world. Old Pammy is getting what she wants. And don't call
它看起来就像一株植物。它在一块木头上，但花盆里没有土壤或水。好吧。好吧。它是一种类似蕨类的植物。好吧。然后，这个设计的理念是，那些养不活其他植物的人却能把这个养活，因为它靠空气生存。我不知道。不对，但我的死掉了。这就像是一个花哨的奇亚宠物吗？不，不。它是空气凤梨。它曾经是一株空气凤梨。它以前是。天哪，你和帕姆都养不活植物。我们确实养不活。好吧，听着，帕姆接下来要在她的独白镜头里迎来高光时刻了。好了，各位。她要开始直接面对大家了。她要开始索取自己想要的东西了。她说，世界小心，老帕姆尼要得到她想要的了。别叫
me Pammy. Yeah. I get that quoted to me a lot. Do you really? Yeah. And don't call me Pammy. The things people quote us are so different. Like I get poop is raining from the ceilings poop. Well, we had a fan question from Ashley Portugal and Stephanie Shipman Barani. In this episode, when Pam decides she's going to be more assertive and she says, and don't call me Pammy, it kind of leads us to believe that she doesn't like that nickname. But in the next episode, when Roy and Pam are talking at the diner, he calls her Pammy. Do you think that was a way of showing how Roy doesn't really know or pay much attention to Pam and her likes and dislikes? Yeah. I think this is planting the seed for this nickname of
我帕姆尼。对啊。这句话经常有人对我说。真的吗？对啊。而且别叫我帕姆尼。大家引用我们的台词真是五花八门。比如我经常听到大便从天而降，大便。好吧，我们有一个来自阿什利·葡萄牙和斯蒂芬妮·希普曼·巴拉尼的粉丝提问。在这集里，当帕姆决定要变得更有主见时，她说，别叫我帕姆尼，这让我们觉得她其实并不喜欢这个绰号。但在下一集里，当罗伊和帕姆在小吃店聊天时，他又叫她帕姆尼。你觉得这是一种展现罗伊根本不了解或不太关注帕姆及其喜好厌恶的方式吗？对啊。我觉得这其实是在为这个绰号做铺垫
Pammy that she's probably said, I don't love that nickname. And he just is the guy who's like, oh, whatever, tickle, tickle Pammy. Yeah. And you're like, no, I actually mean it. Like, I really don't like being called Pammy. And he's like, okay, Pammy. Yeah. Right. And you're, then you just give up. And you're like, okay. Okay, fine. Yeah, I think it is just that thing where Roy just, he just kind of doesn't see her. He tried, but they're just not meant to be together. Now Dwight and Michael have arrived incredibly early to the party. There are catering bands and guys carrying in flowers. Dwight realizes pretty quickly that Michael is dressed like the servants. That's what he calls them. Yeah. And then they, of course, have to change clothes in the
帕姆尼，她可能已经说过，我不太喜欢这个绰号。而他就是那种会说，哦，管他呢，挠挠痒，帕姆尼。对啊。然后你会觉得，不，我是认真的。我是真的不喜欢别人叫我帕姆尼。然后他说，好吧，帕姆尼。对啊。没错。然后你就放弃了。然后你会想，好吧。好吧，好吧。对啊，我觉得这正是那种情况，罗伊他就是，他有点看不到她。他努力过，但他们注定不是一路人。现在德怀特和迈克尔早得离谱地到达了派对现场。有餐饮公司的货车和搬花的人。德怀特很快意识到迈克尔穿得像个仆人。他是这么称呼他们的。对啊。然后他们当然不得不去
driveway. And once again, we see Dwight's belly. Someone track that. How many plants die and how many times do we see Dwight's belly? Well, I love it that Michael says, only good friends arrive early to a party. So the best way to become a good friend is to come early. Yeah. That's what you do. That's his strategy. His strategy is to be the first ones there and the last ones to leave. And then you're going to love him. You know, that reminds me of Ellie Kemper. You know, Ellie Kemper had a role to always be the last person at a party. I know. And she is fun. And you sort of adopted that with her. Yeah, because she told me that once and I was like, oh, I'm always the first one at a party. I like to come in the early part and here's why. I'm not going to come so
车道上换衣服。我们再次看到了德怀特的肚子。谁来统计一下。到底有多少植物死掉，我们又看到了多少次德怀特的肚子？不过我喜欢迈克尔说的那句，只有好朋友才会早到派对。所以成为好朋友的最佳方式就是早到。对啊。这就是你要做的。这就是他的策略。他的策略就是做第一批到的人和最后一批走的人。然后你就会爱上他。你知道，这让我想起了艾丽·肯珀。你知道艾丽·肯珀有一个原则，总是做派对上最后一个人。我知道。她很有趣。你有点模仿了她这一点。对啊，因为她曾经告诉我这个，然后我就想，哦，我总是派对上第一个到的人。我喜欢早点去，原因如下
early that you're just getting out of the shower. Okay. And your house isn't ready. I like to get there early. I get my face time with the host, you know, get to have a sort of meaningful conversation because they're not juggling a lot of people yet. And then I'm there as everyone arrives and I get to chit chat with everyone. I feel overwhelmed when I enter a party and it's like two hours in. I'm like, oh my gosh, it's like too much like instant party for me. I need to ease into a party. I need the population of the party to grow around me slowly. I think this is your metaphor for life though, Jenna, I feel like you need to ease into situations. Yeah, well, I have a lot of social anxiety. So that my way of navigating large social situations is to ease in.
我不会早到得你刚好在洗澡。好吧。而且你的房子还没准备好。我喜欢早点到。我能和主人有面对面的交流，你知道，能进行一次有意义的对话，因为他们还没应付一大群人。然后等所有人到达时我都在场，我可以和每个人闲聊。当我走进一个已经进行两个小时的派对时，我会感到不知所措。我心想，天哪，对我来说这就像是太强烈的即时派对感了。我需要慢慢融入派对。我需要派对的人气慢慢围绕着我增长。我觉得这是你对生活的一种隐喻，珍娜，我觉得你需要慢慢融入各种情况。对啊，好吧，我有很强的社交焦虑。所以我应对大型社交场合的方式就是慢慢融入。
I don't like an instant crowd. I like the instant crowd. I want to jump in. I want the music thumping. I want everyone to have had like a little bit of a cocktail. The pressure's off on me. I can just show up and just be part of the flow. You get there early. I don't know, Jenna, you might get stuck in a conversation that goes on forever. Well, that happens. That happens. I'll take it. I'd rather do that than the other thing. And also, if you come early and you chat with the host, if I start to get overwhelmed, if my anxiety gets too high, I reshex it. I can leave. You just fade out. But I was there. Everyone knows I was there, right? And then just the social sort of like obligation is completed. Do I sound like fun?
我不喜欢即时热闹的人群。我喜欢即时热闹。我想直接跳进去。我想要震耳欲聋的音乐。我希望每个人都喝了一点鸡尾酒。我身上的压力就卸下了。我可以直接出现并融入氛围。你总是到得很早。我不知道，珍娜，你可能会陷入一场没完没了的对话中。好吧，确实会这样。确实会这样。我认了。我宁愿那样也不愿经历另一种情况。而且，如果你早到并和主人聊天，如果我开始感到不知所措，如果我的焦虑太高，我可以重置。我可以离开。你只是默默淡出。但我确实去过了。每个人都知道我去过了，对吧？然后这种社交义务就完成了。我听起来很有趣吗？
You are fun. You actually are a ton of fun. I am fun. And you're a ton of fun. It's just so fascinating to me. You and I have all of these core things that are so the same. And then all of our social stuff is completely different. It's so true. I always say Angela's house is like an episode of 3's company. There's just people coming through the door randomly at all times. It's true. I'm just like, come on in. I'm out back. Come down the driveway. It's like your neighbor, your contractor. I don't know. Literally anyone coming on over. Creed comes with his guitar. I know. And I'm like, make an appointment. Make an appointment. Show up on time. I need to ready myself for the social interaction.
你很有趣。你其实相当有趣。我很有趣。你也很相当有趣。这对我来说太神奇了。你和我有很多核心的事情是完全一样的。然后我们所有的社交方式又完全不同。确实如此。我总是说安吉拉的家里就像是情景喜剧《三人行》的一集。随时都有人在随机进出大门。确实。我总是说，请进。我在后院。从车道走下来。就像你的邻居，你的装修承包商。我不知道。字面意义上任何人都可以过来。柯里带着他的吉他来。我知道。然后我就说，预约。请预约。按时出现。我需要为社交互动做好心理准备。
Okay. So now the whole gang is arriving to poor Richards. And I have a little bit of poor Richards trivia, Jenna. Oh, is this about the real poor Richards? Because we had two people write in Lucas. Bundros and Andrew L said, is poor Richards a real pub that people can go to today? And if so, where is it? Yes, it is a real pub. And it is in Scranton, Pennsylvania. And here's the thing that was kind of interesting, Jenna, where we shot in Los Angeles was attached to a bowling alley, right? Yep. So is poor Richards. It is not a standalone bar. It is part of a bowling alley. Yes. Is the bowling alley called poor Richards? No, the bowling alley is its own thing. Here's the cool thing. Poor Richards actually does have a door that goes into the bar from the outside.
好吧。现在一帮人都到达了“穷理查德”酒吧。我有一点关于“穷理查德”的小知识，珍娜。哦，这是关于现实中的“穷理查德”吗？因为有两个粉丝来信，卢卡斯·邦德罗斯和安德鲁·L说，“穷理查德”是人们今天可以去的真实酒吧吗？如果是的话，它在哪里？是的，它是一个真实的酒吧。它在宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿。有趣的是，珍娜，我们在洛杉矶拍摄的那个地方其实连着一个保龄球馆，对吧？没错。“穷理查德”也是这样。它不是一个独立的酒吧。它是保龄球馆的一部分。是的。保龄球馆叫“穷理查德”吗？不，保龄球馆是独立的。酷的地方在于，“穷理查德”确实有一扇从外面直接通往酒吧的门。
But when you go into the bar, there's a whole section of it that's just opens out into the bowling alley. Wow. Yeah. That's exactly what it's like at Pickwick. Yeah. And right next to the door to go inside is like an old timey looking wooden plaque thing that says poor Richards. And I have a photo I took by it. Actually, in 2018, my husband and I were randomly driving through Pennsylvania. And I was like, Oh my God, it's a good hour and a half out of the way. But let's go to Scranton and we drove to Scranton and we drove all around and I said, let's go to poor Richards and grab a beer. But it was closed. Oh, no. I know. So I took all these pictures by the plaque. But years and years ago, 2017, I was there and I went inside poor Richards
但当你走进酒吧时，里面有一大片区域是直接通向保龄球馆的。哇。对啊。这跟皮克威克酒吧一模一样。就在进门旁边，挂着一个复古风格的木制牌匾，上面写着“穷理查德”。我有一张在那儿拍的照片。其实在2018年，我和我丈夫偶然开车经过宾夕法尼亚州。然后我说，哦天哪，这要绕一个半小时的路呢。但我们去斯克兰顿吧，于是我们开车去了斯克兰顿，到处转了转，我说，我们去“穷理查德”喝杯啤酒吧。但它关门了。哦，不。我知道。所以我一直在那块牌匾旁拍照。但在很多很多年前，即2017年，我在那里
with Brian Baumgartner. What was that like? It was such a blast. We just drank beer and hung out with the folks from Scranton who were all so nice. And I just loved that town. Yeah, me too. I've only been there the one time, but it was so great. It's so fun. But yeah, I have some great photos from from poor Richards. But yeah, you guys, families are bowling and then folks are in the bar just right there on the side. But I want to tell you guys, if you go to poor Richards, here's something that you'll you would never think they have so many different types of French fries tell me more. You can get regular French fries. You can get French fries with gravy, French fries with cheese, French fries with cheese and gravy, chili cheese fries, devil fries, which are smothered
和布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳一起去了“穷理查德”。那是什么感觉？太棒了。我们只是喝着啤酒，和斯克兰顿当地人闲聊，他们人都太好了。我太喜欢那个小镇了。对啊，我也是。我只去过一次，但真的太棒了。太好玩了。不过，对啊，我有一些在“穷理查德”拍的超棒照片。但是呢，你们大家，如果去“穷理查德”，有一点你们绝对想不到，他们有那么多不同种类的炸薯条，快告诉我更多。你可以点普通的炸薯条。你可以点加肉汁的炸薯条，加奶酪的炸薯条，加奶酪和肉汁的炸薯条，辣椒奶酪薯条，恶魔薯条，上面浇了
and hot or mild sauce with your choice of cheese, pizza fries, which have garlic Parmesan seasoned fries with pizza cheese and marinara, bacon cheddar ranch fries, spicy curly fries, or sweet potato fries with salted caramel and marshmallow glaze. Did you order any fries when you were there with Brian? I did. Which ones? I got the plain ones. I didn't realize they had so many others. They were like, what would you like? I was like, I'll have some French fries, you know, because I was just trying to snack. Had I known, I think I would have hit up those bacon cheddar ranch fries. Wow. Mm hmm. I see a road trip in our future. Oh, good Lord. I would love that. You and I driving through Scranton. Come on. We have to make that happen. We've got a list.
特辣或微辣酱汁并加上你选的奶酪，披萨薯条，上面有大蒜帕尔马干酪调味薯条配披萨奶酪和玛利纳拉酱，培根切达牧场薯条，香辣卷薯条，或者配咸焦糖和棉花糖糖霜的红薯条。你和布赖恩去的时候点薯条了吗？点了。点了哪种？我要了原味的。我当时不知道他们有这么多其他选择。他们问，你想来点什么？我说，我来点炸薯条吧，你知道的，因为我只是想吃点零食。我要是早知道，我觉得我一定会点那些培根切达牧场薯条。哇。嗯哼。我觉得我们的自驾游已经在路上了。哦，天哪。我太想去了。你和我开车穿过斯克兰顿。拜托。我们一定要实现这个愿望。我们有个愿望清单。
We've got a list. We've got a bucket list. You guys, you can find out more about poor Richards. You can go to poorrichardspub.net. Well, the gang all sits around the table and they're having some drinks and Ham asked Kevin about his wedding plans. Yeah. And he's like, yeah, we set a date. Everyone's so excited to hear more. And then he's like, you know what, it's complicated and I'd really like some space. I need some space on this. What? At seven minutes, three seconds, there is a fantastic close up of Brian's tiny curled hair on either side of his head. Oh, yes. The ladies in hair and makeup really must hit that curling iron hard. Wait, Jen, I have to show it to you. You have to see. This is a, what should we call this?
我们有个愿望清单。我们有个遗愿清单。各位，你们可以去了解更多关于“穷理查德”的信息。你们可以访问 poorrichardspub.net。好吧，大家围坐在桌旁喝着饮料，帕姆向凯文询问他的婚礼计划。对啊。然后他说，对啊，我们订好日期了。大家都很兴奋想听更多细节。接着他说，你知道吗，这挺复杂的，我真的很想要点空间。我在这件事上需要一些空间。什么？在第七分钟零三秒，有一个非常精彩的特写镜头，是布赖恩头两侧卷曲的小卷毛。哦，对啊。发型和化妆师的卷发棒下手可真够狠的。等等，珍娜，我必须给你看。你得看看。这是一个，我们该怎么称呼这个？
Poofy Kevin Hair Alert? Okay. Wow. That is, I think he needs a haircut is what I see when I look at that. Yeah, I think so. I think maybe his hair had gotten long, but it's a big curl on either side of his head. It kind of looks like he has gigantic ears underneath his hair that they're covering up maybe. It looks like something's hiding in his hair right above his ear. Yeah, it does. Well, listen, Ange, Roy now arrives with his brother Kenny and they're going to buy around a drinks for everyone and I have a lot of questions for you. I also have some thoughts on Roy and Kenny, but I'll save those. Oh, okay. Do you want your questions now then? Yeah, give me some questions. Fan question from Heather Heartline and Molly Pritikin. What was the reason behind Angela going
蓬松凯文发型警报？好吧。哇。那就是，我看到那个的第一感觉是他需要理发了。对啊，我也这么觉得。我觉得可能他的头发长长了，但他头两侧各有一个大卷。看起来有点像他头发底下藏着巨大的耳朵，所以才被遮住了。看起来像是有什么东西藏在他的耳朵上方他的头发里。对啊，确实。好吧，听着，安吉拉，罗伊现在带着他弟弟肯尼到了，他们要请大家喝轮饮料，我对你有很多疑问。我对罗伊和肯尼也有一些想法，不过我先保留。哦，好吧。那你现在想要你的问题吗？对啊，问我一些问题吧。来自海瑟·哈特莱恩和莫莉·普里蒂金的粉丝提问。安吉拉为什么要
to pour Richards with everyone? She didn't really interact with anyone and it didn't really seem like she would want to go out to a bar with her coworkers. Was she lashing out because Dwight went to the other party? But before you answer, fan question from Hannah Klinger, Megan Reed, and Devin B. Is Angela crushing on Roy? Angela, why'd you show up to pour Richards tonight? First of all, at seven minutes, 28 seconds, here is part of that Angela Roy sort of thread that we've seen online. Were they ever a thing? Were they going to be a thing? You can hear off camera when Roy offers to buy everyone a drink. I say, no, thank you, Roy. Kind of like, right? Yeah. Here's what I think is the truth though, guys. We like to think that Angela went
和大家一起去“穷理查德”？她并没有真正和任何人互动，而且看起来她也不太想和同事一起去酒吧。她是在因为德怀特去了另一个派对而发泄吗？不过在你回答之前，还有来自汉娜·克林格、梅根·里德和德文·B的粉丝提问。安吉拉是不是对罗伊有意思？安吉拉，你今晚为什么会出现在“穷理查德”？首先，在第七分钟零八秒，这就是我们在网上看到的那部分安吉拉和罗伊的某种情感线。他们曾经是一对吗？他们打算成为一对吗？当罗伊提出要请大家喝饮料时，你可以听到画外音里的我。我说，不用了，谢谢，罗伊。语气有点像，对吧？对啊。不过各位，我个人觉得真相是这样的。我们喜欢认为安吉拉去
there for Roy because it sounds spassy, but the deleted scenes tell the real story. Oh, do tell. Yes. There was a runner between Angela and Oscar at pour Richards. And I think two things were happening with her character. One, Dwight was busy that night and she felt like going out with everybody, but also it seems at least in the deleted scenes that her and Oscar mend the fences even more. Oh, I don't know if you can tell by watching it, but Angela and Oscar actually aren't at the long table where everyone's sitting. They're at a little two-top right next to it. Oh, and they have dinner together and they have a scene where Oscar has a huge plate of like wings in front of him. He sort of like takes a bite and makes a gross face and he goes,
那里是为了罗伊，因为这听起来很有八卦味，但删减片段揭示了真实的故事情节。哦，快讲讲。对啊。安吉拉和奥斯卡在“穷理查德”之间其实有一条故事线。我觉得她的角色当时有两点考虑。第一，德怀特那天很忙，她觉得跟大家一起出去玩也不错，而且看起来，至少在删减片段里，她和奥斯卡的关系进一步缓和了。哦，我不知道你们看的时候能不能发现，安吉拉和奥斯卡其实并没有坐在大家都在坐的长桌旁。他们坐在旁边的一个小双人桌上。哦，他们一起吃晚饭，还有一个场景是奥斯卡面前有一大盘鸡翅。他咬了一口，做出一个难看的表情，然后说，
these wings are all fat and bone. And Angela is eating one carrot and she goes, oh, this place is disgusting. And then the two of them look at each other and smile and Oscar kind of laughs. Oh my gosh. I love it. Yeah. I think Angela is there because her and Oscar were meant to have these scenes together. Hmm. I love that. Yeah. Great question. Great answer. They don't play the game. They're just there kind of hanging out. I know everybody would love a little Roy Angela controversy, but it never happened, guys. Hmm. Well, let's wait until the next episode because I'm going to have more to say about it then. Okay. All right. But for now, we had a quick fan catch from Luwanda O'Club. When Roy walks into the bar, there is a sign for Fat Tire Beer,
这些鸡翅全都是肥肉和骨头。而安吉拉只吃了一根胡萝卜，她说，哦，这地方真恶心。然后他们两个对视了一眼，笑了笑，奥斯卡还笑出了声。天哪。我太喜欢了。对啊。我觉得安吉拉去那儿是因为她和奥斯卡本来就有一系列这样的对手戏。嗯。我喜欢这样。对啊。好问题。好回答。他们不参与那些戏剧性的东西，只是去那里闲逛。我知道大家都希望有点罗伊和安吉拉的绯闻，但根本没有发生过，各位。嗯。好吧，让我们等到下一集吧，因为到时候我还有更多话要说。好的。好吧。不过现在，我们有一个来自卢瓦达·奥克拉的粉丝快速抓包。当罗伊走进酒吧时，有一个关于“胖轮胎”啤酒的招牌，
which does not distribute to Pennsylvania. Oh, that's a really good catch. A little catch. And then because we mentioned him, I do want to give a shout out to Roy's brother Kenny, who is played by Michael Patrick McGill. He does such a good job. Yeah. He came to the art show. He was amazing. He's here in this episode again. Just great. Just great. And I really buy their relationship as brothers. I really believe it. Not only do they look like they could be related to me, but also I just feel like it really fills in the picture of Roy and his family and his dynamic and why maybe Pam is feeling like she's evolved past that. Well, there's a lot of testosterone in that family. There is. I mean, these are two guys that we're going to go out to get
这种啤酒在宾夕法尼亚州是不做分销的。哦，这是一个非常棒的抓包。一个小细节。然后因为我们提到了他，我确实想对罗伊的弟弟肯尼表示感谢，他由迈克尔·帕特里克·麦吉尔饰演。他演得太棒了。对啊。他来到了艺术展。他太棒了。他在这一集里又出现了。真的很棒。真的很棒。而且我真的觉得他们两个演兄弟很有说服力。我真的很相信。不仅因为他们看起来确实有血缘关系，而且我还觉得这很好地丰满了罗伊以及他的家庭和家庭动态，也解释了为什么帕姆可能会觉得自己已经超越了那种生活。好吧，那个家里有满满的雄性激素。确实。我的意思是，这两个人是要出去喝个
hammered because the jet skis, they didn't get enough money for them or something. Yeah, they didn't sell for what they wanted them to sell for, I guess. But then I feel like Kenny's also just upset that he had to sell them in the first place. Yeah. That's my backstory for Kenny. Yeah. It's both. Before we leave Poor Richards to go back to David Wallace's house, I absolutely love the story that Toby is now going to spend the whole night trying to get that stupid duck. Yes. Well, the other thing too, Angela, is I remember how they spent all this time positioning the claw machine right there at the entrance, and they did that on purpose so that Paul wouldn't be in the background of everything. Exactly. He had to be on set with our director JJ Abrams. He
烂醉，因为他们的水上摩托没卖出足够的钱或者别的什么。对啊，我猜它们没有卖到他们想卖的价格。但我觉得肯尼同时也很难过，因为他一开始就不得不把它们卖掉。对啊。这就是我对肯尼的背景设定。对啊。两方面都有。在我们离开“穷理查德”回大卫·华莱士家之前，我非常喜欢托比接下来要花整晚时间试图抓到那个愚蠢的鸭子的情节。是的。还有一件事，安吉拉，我还记得他们花了多少时间把夹娃娃机摆在入口处，他们这么做是故意的，这样保罗就不会出现在所有镜头的背景里。没错。他必须和我们的导演J·J·艾布拉姆斯一起在片场。他
couldn't be in the background. So it was a very strategic storyline to get him out of every scene. And a very, very funny fix. Yes. Because, yeah, I guess we should remind everybody that whoever wrote the episode, they shadow the director and they help to produce their episode. And so it's hard to both be on camera and being part of those creative conversations over by the monitors. Yeah. All right. Well, let's head back over to David Wallace's house because we forgot to talk about Michael's offering of the potato salad. Yes. We forgot to talk about how he has brought this Tupperware full of potato salad that he has had in his car all day. Well, I love this talking head because he whispers it. And whenever Steve is Michael,
不能出现在背景里。所以这是一个非常具有战略意义的故事线，把他从每个场景里移开。而且是一个非常非常搞笑的补救措施。对啊。因为，对啊，我想我们应该提醒大家，无论谁写了这一集剧本，他们都要协助导演并帮助制作他们的剧集。所以很难既出现在镜头前，又能参与监视器旁边的那些创意讨论。对啊。好吧，那我们回到大卫·华莱士的家里吧，因为我们忘了谈迈克尔带土豆沙拉的事。是的。我们忘了谈他是怎么把这盒装着土豆沙拉的塑料盒带上的，这盒沙拉在他车里放了一整天。不过我非常喜欢这段独白，因为他是耳语着说的。每当史蒂夫扮演迈克尔
like whispers, like it just makes me laugh. He's like, it's been out in my car all day. The sun beaten down on it. Man, he's, yeah. I know. Well, Angela, we had a fan question from Jace Little who says, in light of Michael bringing potato salad to the party, what are your go-to dishes to bring to parties? Do you have a go-to dish when there's a potluck party? Oh, yeah. I mean, I love to bring a side because usually, if you're going to someone's party, I feel like they sort of do the main stuff and then you bring the side. So there's a few that I love. We do this corn dip that I really like. My husband, like, my husband has tons of really great dips. Is that a shameless plug? Bacon with Josh and Ange.com. Tons of really great dips.
用耳语说话时，总是能逗笑我。他说，它在我的车里放了一整天。太阳一直在暴晒它。天哪，他真是，对啊。我知道。好吧，安吉拉，我们有一个来自杰斯·利特的粉丝提问，他说，鉴于迈克尔带了土豆沙拉去派对，你参加派对时通常会带什么拿手菜？当有那种聚餐派对时，你有什么常带的菜吗？哦，对啊。我的意思是，我喜欢带一道配菜，通常情况下，如果你去别人的派对，我觉得他们会准备主食，然后你带配菜。所以我有几道很喜欢的。我们做过一种玉米蘸酱，我真的很喜欢。我丈夫，比如，我丈夫有超级多超级棒的蘸酱。这是一个厚着脸皮的宣传吗？Bacon with Josh and Ange.com。有超多超级棒的蘸酱。
He does that one. Jenna, you had the dip we brought over for Super Bowl last year. Do you remember? Yes. It's so good. It's like a jalapeno chicken dip. It's so good. And then I love these Sriracha Brussels sprouts. I could go on. I've never, I don't think I've ever had those. They're so good that he cooks the Brussels sprouts and then he pours over it this marinade he makes with like soy and I think it's got sriracha and honey. It's so good. That sounds amazing. We're all gone. That sounds amazing. Okay, we'll bring that next time instead of the chicken jalapeno dip. Well, my son's hockey team would always have these like hockey season kickoff parties or holiday parties and it would just be a big potluck situation. They would order pizzas but then,
他会做那个。珍娜，你尝过我们去年超级碗带过去的蘸酱。你还记得吗？记得。太好吃了。那是一种墨西哥辣椒鸡肉蘸酱。太好吃了。然后我喜欢这种是拉差抱子甘蓝。我都说不完了。我觉得我从来没吃过那个。真的太好吃了，他先把抱子甘蓝煮熟，然后把酱汁浇在上面，那酱汁是他用酱油、是拉差辣酱和蜂蜜调制的。听起来太棒了。全吃光了。听起来太棒了。好吧，下次我们带那个去，不带鸡肉墨西哥辣椒蘸酱了。好吧，我儿子的曲棍球队总是会举办这种曲棍球赛季开幕派对或节日派对，通常就是那种大型的聚餐派对。他们会订披萨，然后呢，
you know, everyone brings something too and I have two go-tos. What? One fried chicken from the grocery store. Oh, fried chicken you can't go wrong with, especially with little kids. I was talking like adult party. I have a whole different sides for kids stuff. Okay. Well, we always like to bring fried chicken. A friend of mine actually tipped me off to this offering and it is always a huge hit and I completely stole her idea and we do it all the time. Also, it's really easy because you just pick it up warm from the grocery store on your way to the event. Yes. And no one cares that you didn't make it yourself because they're just happy eating it. Yeah. But then my other thing that I would do for these potlucks is I do these shredded
你知道的，每个人都会带点什么，而我通常有两样必带的。什么？从杂货店买的炸鸡。哦，炸鸡绝对不会出错，尤其是带着小孩子的时候。我刚才说的是成人的聚会。小孩吃的我准备了完全不同的配菜。好吧。总之，我们总是喜欢带炸鸡。其实是一个朋友向我推荐了这个，这总是大受欢迎，我完全偷了她的创意，我们现在经常这样做。而且它真的很方便，因为你在去聚会的路上，顺便就能从杂货店买到热腾腾的炸鸡。对啊。而且没人会在乎是不是你自己做的，因为他们吃得正开心呢。是啊。不过，我参加这种聚会时会带的另一道菜，是我做的这种手撕
chicken mini sliders. Yes, I've had those. Yeah, I love them. I actually put them in a cookbook. Angela, I'm in a cookbook. I know. I am in. I collaborated on this cookbook with Kings Hawaiian and I put this recipe in the cookbook and what you do is you put chicken breasts and you marinate them on low in a crock pot in root beer. That is the secret ingredient and you do that for several hours until they're all soft. Then you drain the root beer, you shred up the chicken, you put a bunch of barbecue sauce in, let that cook on low for a couple hours and then you just bring the whole crock pot along with little slider buns and other accoutrements. Yeah. And you're like, here you go. It's sort of like a spin on like a pulled pork sandwich, but it's chicken. Yeah.
鸡肉迷你小汉堡。对，我吃过那个。对，我超喜欢。我甚至把它收录进了一本食谱里。安吉拉，我进食谱了。我知道。我收到了。我跟夏威夷国王牌（King's Hawaiian）合作了这本食谱，我把这个食谱放了进去。做法是这样的：你把鸡胸肉放进慢炖锅里，用根杰士啤（root beer）小火腌制。这就是秘密武器，你要煮好几个小时，直到它们变软。然后把根杰士啤倒掉，把鸡肉撕碎，加入一大堆烧烤酱，用小火再煮几个小时，接着你只要把整个慢炖锅、小汉堡面包和其他配料一起带去就行了。对啊。然后你就说：“拿去吧。”这有点像手撕猪肉三明治的变体，不过换成了鸡肉。对啊。
Those are my go-tos. I think those are great. Well, Chase Little asked. All right. Well, should we move on because now Dwight is at the buffet. I love a buffet. And he tells the woman, that is fine, lady. You love a buffet. If I say buffet, I should just pause and let you have your moment. I'm always going to have a moment. Well, Dwight tells her that the piece of shrimp she's eating, that the line on the back of the shrimp is poop. Yeah. And you know what? What? It is poop. I looked it up. Oh yeah, it is. So here's what I found out. Yeah. If you're going to cook the shrimp, then you don't have to devein it. They call it deveining, but it's not a vein. It's poop. I think they call it deveining because no one wants to really think about the
这些就是我的首选。我觉得这些都很棒。好吧，蔡斯·利特尔问了。好吧，我们该继续了吗，因为现在德怀特已经到自助餐区了。我超爱自助餐。他告诉那个女的：“这样挺好，女士。”你真爱自助餐。如果我说自助餐，我应该暂停一下，让你享受这美好的时刻。我总是会享受的。好吧，德怀特告诉她，她正在吃的那个虾，虾背上的虾线是屎。是啊。你知道吗？什么？那就是屎。我查过了。哦，对，确实是。所以我发现了这些。对。如果你打算把虾煮熟，其实就不用去虾线了。他们叫去虾线（deveining），但那其实不是静脉，那是屎。我想他们之所以叫去虾线，是因为没人愿意真正去想
fact that we're just scraping poop off their backside. Yeah. So anyway, you should depoop it if you're not going to cook it. Like a shrimp cocktail. Right. But if you're going to cook it, you can just leave the poop there because the cooking will kill the bacteria, at least according to this LA Times article that I read about it. Okay. The end. Do you like shrimp? I mean, wow. This is not that important of a question, but I'm really weighing my answer. I know. I don't hate it, but I don't look for it. Right. I think the most shrimp I eat is maybe in a pad thai. What about you? I love shrimp. I love shrimp. You cannot have relatives in Louisiana and not like shrimp. We talked a lot about food. It's called cocktails, but we're still talking
这样一个事实：我们其实是在刮掉虾屁股后面的屎。对。所以不管怎样，如果你不打算煮熟它，你就应该把屎去掉。比如做虾鸡尾酒。没错。但如果你打算煮熟它，你就可以把屎留在里面，因为烹饪会杀死细菌，至少根据我读到的一篇《洛杉矶时报》关于这个的文章是这样的。好吧。结束。你喜欢虾吗？我的天。这个问题其实没那么重要，但我真的在认真斟酌我的回答。我懂。我不讨厌它，但我也不会主动去找来吃。对。我吃虾最多的时候大概是在泰式炒河粉里。你呢？我超爱虾。我超爱虾。你不可能在路易斯安那州有亲戚却不喜欢虾。我们聊了好多食物。这叫鸡尾酒会，但我们还是在谈论
about food. Yeah. I'm hungry. I am too. I don't even know where we're at anymore. I don't either, but I'm going to share something that's personal. Lady, the other night, I ate an entire box of cheddar bunny snack mix. That's over 1200 calories of cheddar bunnies. Like the cheddar bunnies we get for the kids. Yeah. Oh, lady. Yeah. Lady, were you? I had a moment. Did you have a bad day? Yeah. It was just, you know, where it just feels like you're in a hole and you can't get out. And for whatever reason, my tunnel out of the hole was this box of cheddar crackers. Before I knew it, my fingertips were scraping the bottom of the box. I couldn't believe I'd eaten the whole thing. What were you watching? Were you watching something? Yeah, I was watching the show called
食物。对。我饿了。我也是。我甚至不知道我们聊到哪儿去了。我也不知道，不过我要分享一件很私人的事。女士，前几天晚上，我吃了一整盒切达小兔子零食。那可是超过1200大卡的切达小兔子饼干啊。就是我们买给小孩子的那个切达小兔子。对啊。哦，女士。对啊。女士，你当时是……我当时情绪有点崩溃。你那天过得很糟糕吗？对。就是那种，你知道的，感觉自己掉进了一个坑里，而且怎么也爬不出来。不管出于什么原因，我逃出那个坑的通道就是这盒切达饼干。等我回过神来时，我的指尖已经在刮盒子的底了。我简直不敢相信自己把一整盒都吃完了。你当时在看什么？你在看什么节目吗？对，我在看一个叫
Search Party. Oh, yeah. Yeah, it's really good. Yeah. And I was riveted. And before I knew it, I'd finished all of them. And I'm going to say I felt better the next day. I don't know what the moral of this story is, but how were your BMs? Were you okay? Yeah, I was expecting to have a lot more tummy trouble than I did. I was fine. I was fine. Do you ever want to eat one again? I'm craving it. And I'm not going to buy it, because if it's not in the house, I won't eat it. But I had this problem with the Trader Joe's Cheese Crackers a few years ago, where if I ate one, I ate the whole box. And I managed to get over that. And clearly, my new trigger is the Cheddar Bunny Snack Mix. It's got everything
《搜索聚会》（Search Party）的节目。哦，对。对，真的很好看。对。而且我看得入迷了。不知不觉中，我就把它们全吃完了。我要说的是，第二天我感觉好多了。我不知道这个故事的寓意是什么，不过你上大号还好吗？你没事吧？对啊，我本来以为会肚子疼得很厉害，但并没有。我挺好的。我挺好的。你以后还想再吃吗？我现在很想吃。但我不会去买，因为如果家里没有，我就不会吃。不过几年前我对乔氏超市（Trader Joe's）的奶酪饼干也有过这个问题，只要我吃一个，就会把一整盒吃光。后来我成功克服了那个毛病，很显然，我现在的新的引爆点就是切达小兔子零食。它里面什么都有
in it. It's got not just the Cheddar Bunnies that we love, but it's got like little pretzels and like little cheese at things. And yeah, I was so expecting the story to go differently. I thought you were going to tell it to me and say, I came out on the other side. I am done with junk food. I am only going to eat healthy snacks. But you're like, I ate it all. I felt fine. I'd do it again. So you were expecting like the story to go somewhere is what you're saying. You didn't expect it that it would just hit a wall. Actually, Angela, I have been turning things around and we've been texting about it. I'm trying to do physical exercise three to four days a week and I've been eating really good. But I had this low moment with the box of Cheddar Crackers.
。它不仅有我们最爱的切达小兔子，还有像小蝴蝶饼干和那种小奶酪片。对啊，我本来以为这个故事的发展会不一样。我以为你会跟我说，你已经走出来了。你再也不吃垃圾食品了。你只会吃健康的零食。但你却说：我都吃完了。我感觉很好。我还会再吃一次。所以你是期待故事能有个什么走向，你是这个意思吧。你没想到它就这么撞墙了。其实，安吉拉，我一直在做出改变，我们之前也为此发过短信。我试着一周进行三到四次体育锻炼，而且我最近吃得非常健康。但我偏偏在那盒切达饼干上栽了个跟头，情绪低落了一阵。
I don't know. Sometimes you need to be okay, not being okay, right? Lady, who are you talking to? I got nothing but love for you with all of that. I mean, do you remember that night where it was like 11 o'clock at night? And I was like, well, I guess someone needs a piece of chocolate pie. I guess that person's me. Everyone's gone to bed. I'm not even going to put it on a plate. I'm going to stand inside the fridge and just have a fork and just carve at it. I do remember because you sent me a video message of yourself eating the pie from the fridge. And I'll tell you what, it made me feel better. There you go. There you go. Okay, wait, where are we? Where we are is that Jan and Michael have arrived to the party and they're outside.
我不知道。有时候，你得接受自己状态不好，对吧？女士，你在跟谁说话呢？我对你只有满满的爱。我是说，你还记得那个晚上吗？大概是晚上11点的时候。然后我说，好吧，看来有人需要一块巧克力派。我想那个人就是我。大家都上床睡觉了。我甚至懒得把它放在盘子里。我就站在冰箱里，拿一把叉子直接挖着吃。我还真记得，因为你当时给我发了一个视频消息，拍的是你站在冰箱里吃派的样子。我跟你说，这让我感觉好多了。这就对了。这就对了。好吧，等等，我们现在在哪儿？我们现在的情况是，简和迈克尔已经到达派对现场了，他们还在外面。
And Jan wants Michael to sign some papers waving his right to Sue Dunder Mifflin in the event that their relationship in his mind or in reality interferes with work. I have to tell you, I laughed so hard when she was digging in her trunk and he said, what you looking for? You bring a dip? Like somewhere in Michael's mind, you go to a party, you bring a dip. No matter what party you bring a dip. He's like, everybody must have brought a dip, right? Also, I cannot get enough of Jan and Michael. I love this relationship. I love Malora Hardin so much. She's so phenomenal. God, she's good. Well, you know, she has this amazing talking head where she's like, hey, yeah, this is a calculated risk, you know, upside.
而且简想让迈克尔签署一些文件，放弃他在邓德米夫林公司起诉的权利，以防他们的恋情在迈克尔的心中或现实中干扰到工作。我必须得说，当她在后备箱里翻找东西，而迈克尔问她“你在找什么？你带了蘸酱吗？”时，我真的笑死。就好像在迈克尔的脑海里，去参加派对就得带蘸酱。不管去什么派对你都得带蘸酱。他觉得，每个人肯定都带了蘸酱吧，对吧？还有，我对简和迈克尔简直爱不释手。我太喜欢这段关系了。我超级喜欢梅洛拉·哈丁（Melora Hardin）。她太惊艳了。天哪，她演得真好。你知道，她有一段超棒的内心独白，大致意思是：嘿，是的，这是一次经过计算的风险，你知道的，好处是
I'm going to fall deeply in love and have babies and normalcy, no more self-loathing. Downside, she collapses in on herself like a dying star, right? So in the deleted scenes, she has a much longer talking head. They really trim this down. And lady, she overshares so much, like, it's so uncomfortable to watch. What does she say? I mean, she talks about past relationships. She was like, well, I guess one good thing is I orgasm really easily. So she really over shares. And I was like, oh my God, I see why they deleted it, but it really does show you where Jan is at, her mental space. Well, as soon as he walks in the door, with Jan, they run into David Wallace. They've barely introduced themselves. And
我会陷入爱河，生孩子，过上正常的生活，不再自我厌恶。坏处是，她会像一颗垂死的恒星一样自我坍塌，对吧？所以在被删减的片段中，她有一段长得多的内心独白。他们把这段剪短了很多。而且女士，她真的分享了太多隐私，让人看着极其尴尬。她都说了些什么？我是说，她谈到了过去的关系。她当时说，好吧，我觉得有个好处是我很容易达到高潮。所以她真的分享了太多隐私。当时我就想，天哪，我明白他们为什么要删掉这段了，但它确实展现了简当时的处境和她的心理状态。好吧，就在他俩走进门的时候，他们撞见了大卫·华莱士。他们甚至都还没来得及自我介绍，然后
he says, Jan and I are lovers. He doesn't say Jan and I are dating. First of all, he doesn't need to say that. He doesn't need to clarify their relationship, but he's so excited. And he always refers to them as lovers. And you guys, I don't know if you guys have ever had people like this in your life, but I know a couple who, when they talk about each other, they refer to each other as their lover. And it makes me so uncomfortable every time. Every time. I remember when they got engaged, we were like, oh, tell us your engagement story. And they were like, well, we said to each other, you know what? You are my lover. You are my friend. It's always, they always bring it up. Is it me and Lee? Are you saying you don't like it that I say that Lee and I refer to
他就说：“简和我是恋人。”他没说简和我在约会。首先，他根本没必要这么说。他没必要澄清他们的关系，但他太兴奋了。而且他总是称呼他们为恋人。伙计们，我不知道你们的生活中是否也遇到过这样的人，但我确实认识这样一对情侣，当他们谈论彼此时，他们称呼对方为自己的“恋人”。每次都让我觉得浑身不自在。每次都是。我记得他们订婚的时候，我们说：“哦，跟我们讲讲你们的求婚故事吧。”然后他们说：“嗯，我们对彼此说，你知道吗？你是我的恋人。你是我的朋友。”他们总是这样，总是会提起这个。是我和李吗？你是说你讨厌我这么说吗？讨厌我和李互称
one another as lovers? I want to do it now. The next time I go to a party, I'm going to introduce Lee and I as lovers. This is my lover Lee. Show up really early when there's no one else to buffer your awkward conversation and no one's had a drink yet and be like, my lover and I are early and my lover and I brought cheez-its or whatever. We brought some bunny snacks. My lover told me not to eat so many in the car and I said, lover, you're a salee. I can't wait to do this bit at my next party. Oh, it makes me so uncomfortable. So now we're, the party is going at David Wallace's house and we just have what is possibly one of the most awkward conversations at a party. Yeah. Nine minutes, 52 seconds. Michael tries to hold Jan's
对方为恋人？我现在就想这么干。下次我去参加派对时，我要把我和李介绍为恋人。这是我的恋人李。早早地去，当时还没有别人来冲淡你们尴尬的对话，而且谁也没喝酒，然后就说：“我的恋人和我来得很早，我的恋人和我带了芝士饼干什么的。我们带了一些小兔子零食。我的恋人告诉我不要在车里吃太多，我说，恋人啊，你真是个……我等不及要在下次派对上用这个梗了。”哦，这让我太不舒服了。所以现在，派对正在大卫·华莱士家里进行，而我们迎来了派对上可能最尴尬的一段对话。是的。9分52秒。迈克尔试图拉着简的
hand. He's already, you know, as we said, called her his lover. Then he tries to hold her hand. She won't hold his hand. Then he blows in her face. Then he asks for an appetizer, wants to know if they have any bagel bites. Then Dwight asks for the square footage of the house. Then Michael's like, that's inappropriate. How much does this house cost? And then doesn't Jim like do like a spit take with his drink? Let me tell you something. I was having a cup of tea while I was watching this episode and I happened to be taking a sip right at this moment and Jim and I simultaneously spit into our cups from that line. That line made me laugh all out. I know. It's so awkward and it sends Dwight now on this crazy journey of checking out
手。正如我们刚才所说，他已经叫她“恋人”了。接着他试图去拉她的手。她不让他拉。然后他往她脸上吹气。接着他要前菜，想知道有没有贝果小咬（bagel bites）。然后德怀特问房子的平方英尺是多少。接着迈克尔说：“这太不合适了。这房子多少钱？”然后吉姆是不是把喝的都喷出来了？我跟你说件事。我当时正在看这一集的时候端着一杯茶，正好在这个时候喝了一口，然后吉姆和我同时把茶从嘴里喷到了杯子里，就是因为那句台词。那句台词把我逗得前仰后合。我懂。这太尴尬了，结果让德怀特开始了一场疯狂的探险，去检查
every nook and cranny of their house. Yes. And this is also where Karen is going to start her little prank on Jim. She says to Jim, do you see that guy over there? Because I just think you should know we used to date and it didn't end well. And Jim is like, oh, I didn't like this prank. I didn't like the storyline. Tell me more. Well, I mean, I think it's passive aggressive. I think Karen is maybe still a little stung by the fact that Jim dated Pam and the way she found out about it. And I feel like this is her kind of playful way to make light of it, although it's not something that she feels light about because they've had all these late night talks, but it's her sort of playful way of, I don't know, kind of jabbing him about it. Yeah. And it feels a little sad
他们房子的每一个角落和缝隙。是的。这也是凯伦开始对吉姆搞小恶作剧的地方。她对吉姆说：“你看到那边那个家伙了吗？因为我觉得你应该知道，我们以前约会过，而且结局不太好。”然后吉姆的反应是：哦，我可不喜欢这个恶作剧。我可不喜欢这个剧情线。多讲点。好吧，我的意思是，我觉得这有点被动攻击。我觉得凯伦可能还是有点耿耿于怀，因为吉姆跟帕姆约会过，而且她是通过那种方式发现的。我觉得这是她开玩笑的一种方式，想把这件事轻松化，尽管她对这件事其实一点也不觉得轻松，因为他们聊过那么多次深夜悄悄话，但这就是她的一种玩笑方式，我不知道，有点像是在拿这件事扎他的心。是的。而且我觉得这有点悲伤
and a little desperate to me, Karen. Oh, wow. You said it. I said it. Well, should we talk about this scene with the Scotch? Oh, God, it is so good. There's wonderful moments in the deleted scenes, too. Oh, my God. Well, I have to say, when Steve takes a sip of this Scotch, which David tells us was gifted to him by Lee Iacocca, Steve starts coughing. And it is some of the best liquor coughing I've ever seen in a performance. It was so real. And it's so amazing, too, because there's a great moment in the bloopers where he's like over the gums and through the lips. Like he is not understanding the magnitude of a 20-year-old Scotch given by this amazing man who he thinks discovered the DeLorean. Yes. All of it is wrong. All of it is wrong.
又有点绝望，凯伦。哦，天哪。你真敢说。我就是说了。好吧，我们来聊聊喝苏格兰威士忌的那场戏吧？哦，天哪，太精彩了。被删减的片段里也有很多精彩瞬间。哦，天哪。好吧，我必须得说，当史蒂夫喝了一口这杯苏格兰威士忌时——大卫告诉我们这是李·艾科卡（Lee Iacocca）送给他的礼物——史蒂夫开始咳嗽。那绝对是我见过的表演中最棒的喝酒咳嗽。太真实了。而且太绝了，因为在NG镜头里有一个非常棒的时刻，他说什么“从牙龈到嘴唇”（over the gums and through the lips）。就好像他根本不明白这杯20年的苏格兰威士忌的分量，这是这个由他认为发明了德罗灵（DeLorean）跑车的伟大人物送给他的。没错。全都不对。全都不对。
We had a few people write in about that joke, and they were like, I don't understand the joke about Lee Iacocca and the DeLorean. And this is just a matter of Michael. He's just mixing up his automobile executives. Yes. This is classic Michael, where he gets one part right and then the rest wrong. Yes. So for anyone who doesn't know, Lee Iacocca was best known for developing the Ford Mustang and the Pinto cars. He worked for Ford, but then he went on to work at Chrysler. And he was just this huge automobile executive legend. But here is a fun fact. Wow. Lee Iacocca wrote his autobiography with another writer, William Novak. Holy crap. Yeah. Wait. Yeah. Wait. Wait. Yep. Wait. B.J. Novak's dad was the ghost writer for Lee Iacocca's autobiography.
有几位观众写信给我们提到这个笑话，他们说：“我不太理解关于李·艾科卡和德罗灵跑车的笑话。”这其实就是迈克尔的风格。他只是把汽车高管的名字给混淆了。是的。这就是典型的迈克尔，他能说对一部分，然后剩下的全搞砸了。是的。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，李·艾科卡最著名的成就是开发了福特野马（Mustang）和平托（Pinto）汽车。他在福特工作过，后来又去了克莱斯勒。他绝对是汽车界的一代传奇高管。不过这里有个有趣的冷知识。哇。李·艾科卡曾和另一位作家威廉·诺瓦克（William Novak）合著了他的自传。天哪。真的吗？等等。真的。等等。等等。没错。等等。B.J.诺瓦克的父亲就是李·艾科卡自传的枪手代笔人。
Yeah. Am I getting this right? You are. B.J. Novak's father, William Novak, was a ghost writer, but he was also a writer. Yeah. And he wrote this book with Lee Iacocca. I don't want to tell B.J. stories for B.J., but I just want everyone to know that his childhood was fascinating. And he had just legendary people who worked with his father, who then B.J. had like moments with as a child, as a child. But here's the thing. What's so cool about B.J. stories is that he's a kid meeting legends of different industries. And it just makes me think about the time that my husband Lee was making a movie with Billy Joe Armstrong from Green Day. And Billy Joe would come over to our house and rehearse with Lee for this movie. And my son, who was a big Green Day
真的吗？我没记错吧？没错。B.J.诺瓦克的父亲威廉·诺瓦克是一名枪手代笔人，但他同时也是个作家。是的。他跟李·艾科卡一起合著了这本书。我不想替B.J.讲他自己的私事，但我只想让大家知道，他的童年真的太迷人了。那些与他父亲合作过的人都是传奇人物，而B.J.小时候就跟这些人有过接触，作为小孩子的时候。但关键是。B.J.的故事最酷的地方在于，他作为一个孩子，去结识了各行各业的传奇人物。这让我想起了有一次，我的丈夫李（Lee）和来自绿日乐队（Green Day）的比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗（Billy Joe Armstrong）一起拍电影。比利·乔会来我们家，和李一起为这部电影排练。而我的儿子，他当时是绿日乐队的超级
fan and who is a drummer himself, like hang out with Billy Joe Armstrong and Billy Joe would like show him riffs on the drums and stuff like that. But to my son, he was just like this cool guy named Billy, who was coming over. But one day, like when he's older, I'm going to be like, do you know who was in our house teaching you that whole thing on the hi-hat? Like did that was, do you know who like tuned your bass drum for you that one time? Those Billy Joe Armstrong. Yeah, it's going to be so cool. Jenna, I am there, but I'm there with the office because my kids now love the office. They love it. And they want to watch every episode with me. They'll say, you know, what, what, what episode are you guys doing for office ladies this week? Can we watch
粉丝，而且他自己也是个鼓手，他就跟比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗一起玩，比利·乔还会向他展示打鼓的节奏型之类的东西。但在我儿子眼里，他只是一个叫比利的酷大叔，经常来家里做客。但有一天，等他再大一点的时候，我会对他说：“你知道当年是谁在我们家里教你踩镲的整套技巧吗？你知道当年是谁帮你调好低音大鼓的吗？那是比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗。”没错，这太酷了。珍娜，我也深有同感，不过我是因为《办公室》，因为我的孩子们现在也爱上了《办公室》。他们超爱看。他们想跟我一起看每一集。他们会说：“嘿，你们这周录‘办公室女士’播客要讲哪一集啊？我们能跟你一起看吗？”
with you? And half the time they've seen the episode and it's their second or third viewing of it. And Isabel, there's a photo in our kitchen, Jenna. You know how I have that. I have like a big bulletin board with a bunch of photos on it. And I have a photo of you and I and Isabel on a swing set and I'm holding her and it's from company picnic. Yeah, she had come to set that day at lunch, right? Yeah. So the other morning, Isabel was like, mom, that's company picnic. I was on set for company picnic. I was like, baby, you were on set every week. I just don't have a picture every time. And she was like, Oh my gosh, but it's, it's that moment. It's all becoming really real for her. Yeah. Well, that was BJ's life. He had, you know, all these crazy people,
而且他们有一半时间都已经看过那一集了，这已经是他们的第二或第三遍观看了。而且伊莎贝尔，我们厨房里有一张照片，珍娜。你知道我有一个挂满照片的大公告板。我有一张你、我和伊莎贝尔在秋千上的照片，我抱着她，那是公司野餐那一集拍的。对啊，她那天午饭时间去过片场，对吧？对啊。所以前天早上，伊莎贝尔说：“妈妈，那是公司野餐。我当时就在《公司野餐》的片场。”我说：“宝贝，你每周都在片场。我只是没把每次的照片都拍下来。”然后她说：“哦天哪，但就是那个时刻。这一切对她来说都变得越来越真实了。”对啊。好吧，这就是B.J.的生活。他身边有，你知道的，所有这些疯狂的人，
but he was just like, Oh, you know, my dad's friend Lee came over to write a book about cars. Lee Iacocca. Just Lee Iacocca. Crazy. Not a biggie. Nice guy. Nice fella. Well, lady, we did have a great callback to a character in this scene while they're in the house. We see Dan Gore, who is the regional manager for the Buffalo branch. Yep. Dwight calls him an idiot for not knowing Battlestar Galactica. So I thought that was a nice little callback to season two. And up next, we are going to get into a pretty rowdy drinking game over at poor Richards. Before we do that, we're going to take a little break. All right. What was that sound? Sounds real good. All right. All right, guys, we are back and we are about to start a drinking game called, let me just say, we had a number of
但他当时的反应只是：“哦，你知道的，我爸的朋友李过来写一本关于汽车的书。”李·艾科卡。就是李·艾科卡。太疯狂了。没什么大不了的。人挺好。挺不错的一伙计。好吧，女士，当他们在屋里时，这一幕里确实有一个对某个角色的超级棒的回忆杀。我们看到了丹·戈尔（Dan Gore），水牛城分公司的区域经理。没错。德怀特因为他不知道《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》（Battlestar Galactica）而骂他是白痴。所以我觉得这是对第二季的一个非常棒的小回溯。接下来，我们要去穷理查酒吧（Poor Richard's）玩一场相当喧闹的饮酒游戏了。在此之前，我们先休息一会儿。好吧。刚才那是什么声音？听起来真不错。好了。好了，伙计们，我们回来了，接下来我们要开始一个饮酒游戏，名字叫……让我先说，我们收到了很多
fan questions about what it's called, Tracy Williams, Alex Taylor, Nicole Sabino, Bethany Devish and Samantha Skelly all said, number one, is the drinking game everyone plays at poor Richards a real game? Number two, is it called up chickens or up Jenkins? And number three, where did the writers get the idea from? First of all, yes, this is a real game. It is called up Jenkins, down Jenkins. And I will tell you how Paul found out about it. So Paul's brother Warren went to Kenyon College in Gambier, Ohio. And I was in New York with him. And we were hanging out with his friends from college, Martin and Nelly. This is a game they played in college. We played it all night at a little dive bar in Manhattan. Paul knew about this game from Warren, and he incorporated
粉丝关于这个游戏名字的提问，特雷西·威廉姆斯（Tracy Williams）、亚历克斯·泰勒（Alex Taylor）、妮可·萨宾诺（Nicole Sabino）、贝瑟尼·德维什（Bethany Devish）和萨曼莎·斯凯利（Samantha Skelly）都提问了：第一，大家在穷理查酒吧玩的这个饮酒游戏是真有其事吗？第二，它到底叫“up chickens”还是“up Jenkins”？第三，编剧们的灵感是从哪里来的？首先，是的，这绝对是个真实的游戏。它叫做“up Jenkins, down Jenkins”（起立简金斯，蹲下简金斯）。我来告诉你们保罗是怎么知道这个游戏的。保罗的弟弟沃伦曾在俄亥俄州甘比尔的凯尼恩学院（Kenyon College）上学。当时我在纽约跟他在一起。我们在那里跟他在大学里的朋友马丁和内莉一起玩。这是他们在大学里玩的一个游戏。我们在曼哈顿的一家小潜水酒吧里玩了一整夜。保罗是通过沃伦知道了这个游戏，然后把它写进了
it into the script. Okay, so how exactly do you play? Okay, now, according to Warren, Martin and Nelly from Kenyon College, this is how you play it. There are two teams on opposing sides of a table. You grab a quarter and you pass it underneath as slightly as possible, right? You're passing the quarter under the table to your teammates. And at any time, the opposing team on the other side of the table can say one, two, three up Jenkins. And at that point, every single person has to put their elbows on the table and clench their hands into fists to hide whoever has the quarter, right? Okay. And then the opposing team says one, two, three down Jenkins. And at that point, you slam your hands down to the table, everyone at the same time. You try to do it at the same time to mask
剧本里。好吧，那具体怎么玩呢？好吧，根据沃伦、来自凯尼恩学院的马丁和内莉的说法，游戏规则是这样的。桌子两侧分别坐着两支队伍。你拿一枚硬币，尽可能隐蔽地把它传下去，对吧？你在桌子底下把硬币传给你的队友。在任何时候，桌子对面的对方队伍都可以喊：“一、二、三，起立简金斯！”到了那个时候，每个人都必须把手肘放在桌上，双手紧握成拳头，把藏有硬币的人遮起来，对吧？好吧。然后对方队伍喊：“一、二、三，蹲下简金斯！”到了那个时候，你要把双手同时重重地拍在桌上，所有人必须整齐划一。你们要尽量同时拍下，以此来掩盖
the sound of that quarter hitting the table. Then the opposing team goes down the line and touches every single hand they think doesn't have it, leaving the hand that does have it. Now, okay. Do we know why it's called up Jenkins down Jenkins? Did someone name Jenkins invent it? We don't know why. And when I looked it up on the internet, a few things came up. First of all, Jenkins is a very Welsh name. And apparently, there is a version of this in Wales and it's called tippet. Oh, I don't know. It is also played in Iraq. And it's called M. Hibes, if I'm saying that correctly. Apparently, it's been documented that a version of this game was played by the Native Americans. And it was called hand game. And it's played throughout
硬币击打桌面的声音。然后对方队伍会依次走过每一个人，触摸他们觉得没有硬币的每一只手，最后留下那只藏有硬币的手。现在，好吧。我们知道为什么它叫“up Jenkins down Jenkins”吗？难道是一个叫简金斯的人发明的吗？我们并不知道原因。当我在网上查阅时，出现了一些说法。首先，简金斯是一个非常普遍的威尔士姓氏。显然，威尔士也有一个类似的版本，被称为“tippet”。哦，我不知道。伊拉克也有这个游戏。它被称为“M. Hibes”，如果我没发音错的话。据记载，美洲原住民也玩过这个游戏的某种版本。它被称为“手抓游戏”（hand game），并且在整个
America. There's several different names. It has been referred to as up chickens in Midwestern states, or sometimes it's just called Jenkins. Well, there you have it, folks. I'm sure there's more information out there about up Jenkins down Jenkins. And if you guys have any, let us know. Jenna, do you remember on set me teaching everyone how to play? Yes, I do. I do. You gave a little tutorial and I was so bummed that once again, Angela Martin does not participate. I know you were our teacher, but you are not a participant. No. Well, in the episode, Pam is the one who ends up having the quarter under her hand and Roy is doing the guessing. And he kind of looks at her and he's like, you know, not here to Stanley revealing that Pam has it. And then he says like,
美洲都有流传。它有几种不同的名称。在中西部各州，它有时被称为“up chickens”（起立小鸡），有时干脆就叫“简金斯”。好吧，各位，真相就是这样。我确信网上还有更多关于“起立简金斯，蹲下简金斯”的信息。如果你们知道什么，请告诉我们。珍娜，你还记得在片场我教大家怎么玩的吗？是的，我记得。我当然记得。你做了一个小教程，我当时超级沮丧，因为安吉拉·马丁又一次没有参与。我知道你是我们的老师，但你不是参与者。不。好吧，在这一集中，帕姆成了最后手里拿着硬币的那个人，而罗伊负责猜。他看了她一眼，然后说：“你知道的，这里没有。”结果斯坦利却无意中透露了硬币其实在帕姆手里。然后他说...
Oh, I can just read you like a book. You can't keep anything from me. Oh, and Pam's like, Oh, but I can. And I did. She just feels, I think, super guilty. She's on this track in this episode where she's trying to be more assertive. Remember, she went up to the bar and the bartender gave her the wrong drinks. Yeah. And she mustered up the courage to say, I'm sorry, one of these is supposed to be a light. And I really do think she meant it. And we'll get there when she's like, you know, I want us to have a real chance. And she sees Roy trying and she wants to try. And if this is going to work, then she wants all the cards on the table. Yeah. And part of this sort of being empowered to speak her mind is all just part of that. Well, now there's this little runner that happens at
哦，我简直把你当书一样看透了。你什么都瞒不过我。哦，然后潘就像是，哦，但我可以。而且我做了。我觉得她只是感到非常内疚。她在这集里正处于尝试变得更自信的阶段。还记得吗，她走到吧台前，调酒师给错了她饮料。是的。她鼓起勇气说，不好意思，其中一杯应该是淡啤酒。我真的觉得她是认真的。我们会讲到当她说，你知道，我希望我们能有个真正的机会。她看到罗伊在努力，她也想努力。如果这事能成，那她希望所有底牌都亮在桌面上。是的。而这种重获力量说出自己想法的一部分，其实都是其中的一部分。好吧，现在有个小插曲发生在
the bar that I love. It's so small, but it's these moments that just make the show for me where all of these kids walk in and they are introducing themselves to Creed. He says hi. He knows every single one of them. All of them. And then he's just got this quick little talking head where he's like, Oh, yeah, I run a small fake ID company out of my car using a laminating machine that I swiped from the sheriff's station. That's it. That's it. That's how I know them. Why was I at the sheriff's station? How long have I been doing this business? It's clearly illegal. Well, listen, should we go back to David Wallace's house, lady? Oh, yeah, because things are going off the rails. Oh my God. It's amazing. Well, Karen is continuing her prank
我超喜欢的吧台。它太小了，但正是这些瞬间成就了这部剧，所有这些孩子走进来，他们向克里德自我介绍。他说嗨。他认识他们每一个人。所有人。然后他有一个很简短的单人镜头，他说，哦，是的，我在车里经营一家小型假身份证公司，用的是我从警长局顺来的过塑机。就这样。就这样。我就是这样认识他们的。我当时为什么在警长局？我做这个生意多久了？这显然是违法的。好吧，听着，我们要回大卫·华莱士家吗，女士？哦，是的，因为事情开始失控了。天哪。太棒了。好吧，卡伦继续她的恶作剧
on Jim and they've had a conversation with a couple and she's like, Oh my gosh, did you see the way that woman was just staring daggers at me? I think it's because I dated her husband for a while while they were separated. Yeah. So she's keeping her joke going. Dwight is still inspecting the house. He's testing the smoke detector, the banister. I have to tell you Dwight in this episode really reminds me a lot of a friend of mine who was a contractor. He was a comedian and also a contractor, which is a very funny combination. His name is Pete Holney. He's been in a ton of movies and things. He's very funny, but he would walk through my house and he would like bang on a wall and he'd be like, yeah, this can go. He's like, what? He'd thump a pillar. He'd be
针对吉姆，他们和一对夫妇聊过天，她说，哦天哪，你看到那个女人刚才怎么用眼刀瞪我吗？我觉得是因为我和她丈夫分居期间约会过一段时间。是的。所以她还在继续开玩笑。德怀特还在检查房子。他在测试烟雾报警器、楼梯扶手。我必须告诉你，这集里的德怀特真的让我想起了我的一个朋友，他是个承包商。他是个喜剧演员，同时也是个承包商，这是一个非常搞笑的组合。他叫皮特·霍尔尼。他演过海量的电影和节目。他非常搞笑，但他会走过我的房子，然后敲敲墙，说，行，这个可以拆。他说，什么？他会敲敲柱子。他说
like, you can lose this. He'd get something else. He was like, yeah, you don't need that. I'm like, Pete, what is left of my house? Well, this reminds me a little bit of my dad because my dad is a builder, you know, and not professionally, he's an engineer, but he builds now displays for the Children's Museum in St. Louis, this place called the Magic House. No, your dad is amazingly talented. He's amazingly talented. And by the way, can I say something about my dad that's sort of amazing? So my sister is a school teacher and with the pandemic, their school opened. So they are doing in-person learning. Yeah. And in order to make the space safer for the kids, especially the real little ones who have a hard time keeping their masks on, like the preschool age, my dad built
像，这个可以拿掉。他又弄了点别的。他说，行，你不需要这个。我说，皮特，我的房子还剩什么？好吧，这让我有点想起我爸爸，因为我爸爸是个建筑师，你知道，不是职业的，他是个工程师，但他现在为圣路易斯的儿童博物馆建造展览，那个地方叫魔法屋。不，你爸爸才华横溢。他才华横溢。顺便说一句，我能说一件关于我爸爸的了不起的事吗？我妹妹是一名学校老师，随着疫情爆发，他们的学校开学了。所以他们在进行面授教学。是的。为了给孩子们创造一个更安全的空间，特别是那些很难戴好口罩的小小孩，比如学龄前儿童，我爸爸建造了
30 Plexiglas screens for the preschool classes so that they could separate all the kids by these little... That is amazing. Screens. He just did that in his free time and delivered them all up to the school. He's amazing. That is amazing. I know my sister, Janet, listens to our podcast and her and the other teachers made little screens using Legos and Plexiglas. They could have used your dad. He was so excited. He had a whole template for it and he had a whole little assembly line he created. But I could kind of see my dad. Because later in the episode, Dwight's like, this was a great party. He had a fantastic time. I think my dad's favorite time at a party would be if he could walk around and just structurally examine a home. Yeah. He doesn't need small talk.
30块有机玻璃隔板供学龄前班级使用，这样他们就可以把所有孩子用这些小……太棒了。隔板。他只是在闲暇时间做了这个，并把它们全部送到学校。他太棒了。太棒了。我知道我妹妹珍妮听我们的播客，她和其他老师用乐高和有机玻璃制作了小隔板。他们本来可以用上你爸爸。他太兴奋了。他为此做了一个完整的模板，还创造了一条小型装配线。但我有点能理解我爸爸。因为在这集后面，德怀特说，这是一次很棒的派对。他玩得非常开心。我想我爸爸在派对上最喜欢的时光，莫过于能到处走走并从结构上检查一栋房子了。是的。他不需要闲聊。
He just needs a crawl space and a flashlight. Yeah. And he might fix something that if you've got like a wonky doorknob, that'll be fixed when he leaves. I love that. Well, Michael is very impressed by the vanilla candles. What a weird foreshadow, right? For Jan's candle business. I know. He really wants David Wallace to go to sandals with him. He's like, you would not believe how low this lady can go in the limbo. Jan is horrified. She's like, excuse us. And she pulls him into the bathroom and then she starts just attacking him. Like, she's like, throw me up against the wall right here. Take me right here. And he's like, Jan, what do you stop getting undressed? This is inappropriate. And she goes, oh, I'm inappropriate.
他只需要一个狭窄空间和一个手电筒。是的。而且如果你的门把手有点松，他可能会顺手修好，等他走的时候就修好了。我太喜欢了。好吧，迈克尔对香草蜡烛印象深刻。多奇怪的伏笔，对吧？为了珍的蜡烛生意。我懂。他真的想让大卫·华莱士和他一起去桑德尔度假村。他说，你简直不敢相信这位女士在 limbo（林波舞）里能弯得有多低。珍吓坏了。她说，失陪一下。然后她把他拉进浴室，接着就开始攻击他。就像，她说，现在就把我推到这面墙上。就在这里要了我。而他说，珍，你别再脱衣服了？这很不合适。她说，哦，我很不合适。
Get out of my way. She's, I mean, the woman is unhinged. It's so incredible because it really, it's like she's some sort of like a masochist or something, right? Like she just, there's something in the humiliation that turns her on. Listen, she said this could go two ways. One is where she collapses into herself like a dying star. It's like a self-fulfilling prophecy. She is just going to do that. Well, now we come up on one of my favorite scenes at the party. Is it Dwight wanting the rocking chair? Yes. We had a fan question from Megan Lou Cherony, who said, I read that David Wallace's son is played by Greg Daniel's son, Owen Daniels. That is correct. That is true. It was so fun to have him on set. And, you know,
别挡我的路。她，我的意思是这个女人精神失常了。太不可思议了，因为真的，这就像她某种受虐狂之类的，对吧？就像她，屈辱中有些东西让她兴奋。听着，她说这可能会有两种结果。一种是她像一颗垂死的恒星一样向内坍缩。这就像是一个自我实现的预言。她就要这么做了。好了，现在我们迎来了派对上我最喜欢的场景之一。是德怀特想要那把摇椅吗？是的。我们收到了来自梅根·刘·切罗尼的粉丝提问，她说，我听说大卫·华莱士的儿子是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯的儿子欧文·丹尼尔斯扮演的。那是真的。千真万确。能让他上节目太有趣了。而且，你知道，
it's just, it's so amazing now, Jenna, to see these kids as they're older. Talk about feeling old. Oh my gosh. Owen's like a, he's like a young man now, you know? It's crazy. I know, I know. The scene is just so good. And we had a fan catch from Nora A, Elijah Brown, and Ashley Dodd, who said this, in this episode, when Dwight is in David Wallace's son's room, and he's sitting in the rocking chair, he asked the kid where it's from and says he wants one. In the final season, we can clearly see that Dwight got the same rocking chair. Get out. They must have saved it and put it at Shrew Farms. That's such a great, tiny detail to catch. I'm very impressed. I love that. That's amazing.
珍娜，现在看到这些孩子长大成人，真是太神奇了。说起感觉自己老了。天哪。欧文就像个，他现在像个年轻小伙子了，你知道吗？太疯狂了。我懂，我懂。这个场景实在是太棒了。我们收到了诺拉·A、伊利亚·布朗和阿什利·多ッド的粉丝爆料，他们说：在这集里，当德怀特在大卫·华莱士儿子的房间里，他坐在摇椅上，他问那孩子这是从哪来的，并说他也想要一个。在最后一季中，我们可以清楚地看到德怀特得到了同一把摇椅。少来。他们一定把它保存下来并放到了施鲁特农场。捕捉到这么棒的微小细节。我印象深刻。我太喜欢了。太棒了。
Well, then David Wallace asked Jim if he wants to go shoot hoops out back. Well, while they're playing basketball, they hear like a clamoring noise and they look up and there's Dwight on the flippin' roof and he's like busted up part of the chimney. Yes, we got mail about this, Angela. Stephanie T, Phoebe B, Violet F, Abby M, and Iris Bell all wrote in to say, is rain really climbing on the roof when Dwight is inspecting the chimney? How did rain get on the roof? Because in previous podcasts, you mentioned that you guys had to ride a crane to get on the roof, so how did this work? Oh, good question. I didn't even think about that, but it looks like he's really up there. He's really up there, but the chimney is fake.
好吧，然后大卫·华莱士问吉姆想不想去外面投篮。好吧，当他们在打篮球时，他们听到类似碰撞的噪音，抬头一看，德怀特竟然在见鬼的屋顶上，而且他还砸坏了一部分烟囱。是的，我们收到了关于这个的邮件，安吉拉。斯蒂芬妮·T、菲比·B、维奥莱特·F、艾比·M和艾瑞斯·贝尔都写信来问，德怀特检查烟囱时，雨真的在爬屋顶吗？雨是怎么爬上屋顶的？因为在之前的播客中，你们提到你们必须坐起重机才能上屋顶，那这是怎么运作的？哦，好问题。我甚至都没想过这个，但看起来他真的在上面。他真的在上面，但烟囱是假的。
Here is what Kentopedia told me. They had to build a chimney and rig it onto the roof of the house, because where those guys were playing basketball, if you looked up at the roof, there was no chimney there. So that is a fake chimney. Rain had to climb onto the roof using a ladder. He was assisted by a stunt coordinator, and after he got on the roof, the stunt coordinator attached a little safety line to Rain's waist, fed it through his pant leg so that in the event that he slipped, he wouldn't fall off the roof. So they had him like sort of like chained to the roof. He wouldn't fall off the roof, but he would get a horrendous wedgie. Yes. Yes. He'd get a wedgie to end all wedgies. I cannot believe they built a fake chimney.
这就是肯托百科全书告诉我的。他们不得不建造一个烟囱并把它架在房子的屋顶上，因为男士们打篮球的地方，如果你抬头看屋顶，那里根本没有烟囱。所以那是个假烟囱。雨不得不借助梯子爬上屋顶。他在特技统筹的协助下上去的，他上去后，特技统筹把一条安全绳系在雨的腰上，从他的裤腿穿过去，这样万一他滑倒了，就不会从屋顶掉下来。所以他们把他像那样拴在屋顶上。他不会从屋顶掉下来，但他会遭遇可怕的夹阴。是的。是的。他会遭遇惨绝人寰的夹阴。我简直不敢相信他们建了个假烟囱。
Wow. That is so wild. Well, and then back inside the party, Angela is a little couplet that I just love, and so did a lot of other people. I bet it happens at 16 minutes 41 seconds. Is it, hi, Jan, not too good? Hey, Jan, not too good. Well, Alana Wynne-Cole, Rose Dowell, Julia Tyson, and Hannah Hawke all wrote in saying it was one of their favorite moments. And they love how there's this runner of Jan not responding correctly to the greeting that someone has given her. Yes, because we saw this in the initiation when Pam says, hi, and Jan goes, I'm great. Yes, exactly. Amazing. Well, Jenna, I love that couplet of dialogue, but I also loved Michael's talking head. I thought Paul, as the writer,
哇。太疯狂了。好吧，然后回到派对里面，安吉拉有一小段对白我超级喜欢，很多人也一样。我打赌它发生在16分41秒。是不是，嗨，珍，不太好？嘿，珍，不太好？好吧，阿兰娜·韦恩-科尔、罗丝·道尔、朱莉娅·泰森和汉娜·霍克都写信说这是他们最喜欢的时刻之一。他们喜欢珍对别人打招呼的回应方式不对的这个梗。是的，因为我们在入职仪式上看到过，当潘说嗨时，珍说，我很好。是的，完全正确。太棒了。好吧，珍娜，我喜欢那段对白，但我也很喜欢迈克尔的单人镜头。我觉得保罗作为编剧，
knocked this out of the park because this is really how people talk, how they process information. And Michael is saying, wow, you know, she really likes my potato salad. And I just bought it at the store. I wish I could make potato salad like that. I mean, I guess it's really simple. It's potatoes and mayonnaise. There is something very wrong with Jan. He does this pivot, but I feel like that's real life. I feel like that's how you're talking about something like, oh, yeah, there was such a, you know, a lovely breeze out today. And I don't think we can be married anymore. You're like, what? Well, let me tell you, I was completely distracted during this talking head, Angela, behind Steve's shoulder, sitting at what looks like a vanity. Yeah.
这集写得太精彩了，因为这真的是人们说话的方式，他们处理信息的方式。迈克尔在说，哇，你知道，她真的很喜欢我的土豆沙拉。我明明是在商店买的。我希望我也能做出那种土豆沙拉。我的意思是，我想这真的很简单。就是土豆和蛋黄酱。珍身上有很大的问题。他来了个急转弯，但我觉得这很现实。我觉得这就是你谈论某些事情的方式，哦，是的，今天微风真舒服啊。我不觉得我们能继续结婚了。你会想，什么？好吧，我告诉你，安吉拉，在这个单人镜头期间我完全分心了，在史蒂夫的肩膀后面，坐着一个看起来像梳妆台的东西。是的。
Did you see it looks like it is a woman with really, really, really long blonde hair or something? It looks like something out of like the ring. Remember that horror movie, The Ring? Yeah, wait, so there's like blonde hair coming over her face or it's the back of her head. I was like, what? Who is, oh, is that a person? Is it a wig on a stand? What is the hairy object over his shoulder? And I could never figure it out. No, I didn't catch it at all. I think I was so like riveted on Steve, but now I need to see it. Well, remember when we couldn't figure out what the weird fluffy thing was by Phyllis's desk and we figured out that it was a feather duster? Thanks to Cody. Cody knew immediately. Well, I don't know if we need to get Cody on this,
你看到了吗，它看起来像是一个头发非常非常非常长的金发女人什么的？看起来像《午夜凶铃》里的东西。还记得那部恐怖电影《午夜凶铃》吗？是的，等等，所以有金发垂到她的脸上，还是那是她的脑后勺？我当时想，什么？是谁，哦，那是个人吗？是支架上的假发吗？他肩膀上那个毛茸茸的东西是什么？我怎么也琢磨不透。不，我一点也没注意到。我想我当时太被史蒂夫吸引了，但现在我必须去看看。好吧，还记得我们当时弄不清菲利斯办公桌旁边那个奇怪毛茸茸的东西是什么，后来发现是个鸡毛掸子吗？多亏了科迪。科迪一眼就认出来了。好吧，我不知道我们是否需要让科迪来处理这个，
but what is over Michael's shoulder during this talking head? Okay. Someone tell me. It's around 16 minutes, 50 seconds, if anyone knows. Cody, we're going to move on, but could you take a look at it and weigh in? 16 minutes, 50 seconds. Well, while she's doing that, I feel like we should go back to poor Richard's Angela because some shiitake is about to go down so much shiitake and so quickly out of nowhere. Yeah. Should we talk about it? Yeah, I mean, Pam and Roy are at the bar. Looks like it's been a pretty successful night. It definitely seems like Roy has had a few cocktails. He seems a little tipsy. And Pam says she wants to make a fresh start with him. No secrets. He says, me too. And then she says
但迈克尔在这个单人镜头里肩膀上到底是什么？好吧。谁来告诉我。大约在16分50秒，如果有人知道的话。科迪，我们要继续了，但你能看一看并发表下意见吗？16分50秒。好吧，当她这么做的时候，我觉得我们应该回到可怜的理查德酒吧，安吉拉，因为有些狗屎事要发生了，这么多狗屎事，而且突然毫无征兆。是的。我们要聊聊吗？是的，我是说，潘和罗伊在吧台。看起来这是一个相当成功的夜晚。看起来罗伊确实喝了几杯鸡尾酒。他看起来有点微醺。潘说她想和他重新开始。没有秘密。他说，我也是。然后她说
a month before their wedding at the casino night, her and Jim kissed. She says, I kissed Jim. And she said he had told her his feelings and then Roy's like, wait, Jim came onto you? And she's like, listen. And he's like, I am listening. That's the problem. And he just goes from zero to 60. He throws a beer bottle or something at that mirror in its shaders. Yes. Yes. Well, I asked Kent about that because I remember that moment and I remember something happened there that wasn't supposed to happen. I was like, Kent, was that mirror meant to break? Because when I was watching the scene, I was like, what was the mishap with that mirror? So he said the glass mirror was a prop sign. It was rigged with safety glass. And Roy was meant
在赌场之夜婚礼前的一个月，她和吉姆接吻了。她说，我和吉姆接吻了。她说他向她表白了心意，然后罗伊说，等等，吉姆对你主动投怀送抱？她说，听我说。他说，我在听。这就是问题所在。他的情绪瞬间从0飙升到100。他把一个啤酒瓶之类的东西砸向那面镜子，碎了一地。是的。是的。好吧，我问过肯关于那件事，因为我记得那个时刻，而且我记得那里发生了某种不该发生的事。我说，肯，那面镜子是打算砸碎的吗？因为我在看这一幕时，我心想，那面镜子出了什么事故？所以他说那面玻璃镜子是个道具标志。它装配了安全玻璃。罗伊本来打算
to hit it with his beer bottle. And that all the bottles that Roy and Kenny are throwing are all made of candy glass. But he checked the production report and guess what it said? What it said? He said that in one of the takes, I got hit in the face with some of the candy glass when it like sprayed off of the mirror. So that was my memory. I was like, something happened with that mirror. But he said the production report said that I was fine and able to finish the day. So there you go. I kind of do remember like a little bit of a hullabaloo because some stuff flew in your face. Like I enjoyed my memory. Well, and then I mean, Pam was like, this is over. And he's like, it is over, you know,
用他的啤酒瓶砸它。而且罗伊和肯尼扔的所有瓶子都是用糖玻璃做的。但他查了制作报告，你猜上面写了什么？写了什么？他说在其中一个镜头里，当糖玻璃从镜子上溅开时，我被一些糖玻璃砸到了脸上。所以这就是我的记忆。我当时想，那面镜子出事了。但他说制作报告上说我没事，能够完成当天的拍摄。所以你看。我确实隐约记得有点小骚动，因为有些东西飞到了你脸上。就像我挺喜欢我的记忆的。好吧，然后，我是说，潘当时说，这结束了。而他说，确实结束了，你知道，
and he just starts wailing stuff at the wall and out of nowhere. I mean, where the hell has Kenny been? He just shows up and starts breaking shit. Yeah. Well, also, I don't know if you noticed at 18 minutes, 51 seconds, there is someone else in this scene and a number of people wrote in pointing it out. Kevin. Yes. Kevin. And he doesn't have his hands like clenched and little fists like he's ready to go just in case. Yes. Kimberly Willis, Heather R, Shannon R, Corey Haley, and Lauren Greenlee all said that when Roy starts the fight at the bar and he's yelling and throwing the glass in the lower left corner of the screen, you can see Kevin standing there fists clenched ready to defend Pam if Roy comes at her. It was such a sweet moment during a tough scene. Was
然后他开始毫无征兆地把东西往墙上猛砸。我的意思是，肯尼到底去哪了？他一出现就开始砸烂东西。是的。还有，我不知道你有没有注意到在18分51秒，这个场景里还有另一个人，好几个人写信指出了这一点。凯文。是的。凯文。而且他没有把手紧握成小拳头，好像随时准备冲上去的样子。是的。金伯利·威利斯、希瑟·R、香农·R、科里·海利和劳伦·格林利都说，当罗伊在吧台挑起争端，大喊大叫并砸碎玻璃时，在屏幕的左下角，你可以看到凯文站在那里，紧握拳头，准备在罗伊扑向潘时保护她。在艰难的一幕中，这是一个非常温馨的时刻。是
this scripted? No, it was not in the script. Brian just improvised that, huh? I guess so. I think he did. It was a really great choice. Yeah. Yeah. Well, he's told Jim before he's got his back, but let's hope it doesn't come to that. So that's, that's, I think Kevin being there for Pam and Brian just, that was part of his story that he had written for his character. Well, then we also got a really touching letter, Angela, from Paula Marquez, who says, I am grateful for that scene with Roy going violent at poor Richards and Pam's reaction to it. Many girls, me included, still believe that their partner's violent reactions are their own fault and that they must apologize for whatever triggered them that way. The first time I watched this
剧本里写的吗？不，剧本里没有。布莱恩是即兴发挥的，对吧？我猜是的。我想他是。这是一个非常棒的选择。是的。是的。好吧，他之前告诉过吉姆他会支持他，但我们希望不要走到那一步。所以，我认为凯文在现场支持潘，而布莱恩这样做，那是他为自己的角色所写的故事的一部分。好吧，接着我们还收到了一封非常感人的信，安吉拉，来自保拉·马尔克斯，她说，我很感激罗伊在可怜的理查德酒吧大打出手以及潘的反应的那场戏。许多女孩，包括我在内，仍然认为伴侣的暴力反应是他们自己的错，她们必须为任何引发这种反应的事情道歉。我第一次看这集
episode and I saw Pam walking away from Roy stating that they were over was very remarkable for me, but it didn't make much sense to me. At first, I still thought that she had to calm him down, maybe apologize and work on their relationship. But after a while, I realized that it wasn't her responsibility and she was so right to stand up for herself and walk away from him. And, and I just want to say that it really means so much to me when women, young women, young women especially, find strength through Pam's story on this show. And I feel like it is a way that her story is impactful and it's just really meaningful to me in being the person who got to play Pam. I love that. And I'm so glad that that scene was able to resonate with her.
并看到潘离开罗伊并宣称他们结束了，这对我来说非常显眼，但对一开始的我来说并不是很有意义。起兴时，我还是觉得她必须安抚他，也许应该道歉并维系他们的关系。但过了一会儿，我意识到这并不是她的责任，她坚持自我并离开他是绝对正确的。而且，我只想说，当女性，尤其是年轻女性，通过这部剧里潘的故事找到力量时，这对我的意义真的太重大了。我觉得这是她的故事产生影响的一种方式，对于扮演潘的我来说，这真的意义非凡。我太喜欢了。我很高兴那一幕能够与她产生共鸣。
Well, Jenna, I don't know if you caught, but there is a song playing under the whole scene while Pam and Roy are talking and then it kind of crescendos as Roy and Kenny start smashing things. Yes. It is Carry On My Wayward Son by Kansas, which I thought was an interesting choice. Yes. Right. Well, the party has also ended over at David Wallace's and Michael and Jan are driving home and, oh, this car ride. This is maybe one of my favorite scenes that I didn't know was a favorite scene until I watched it for this rewatch. I just can't get enough of Michael and Jan. They're such a hot mess and they're so fun to watch. And Malora is so good. You know, Jan is like, I feel sick. I just feel sick and he's like, you can eat the potato salad,
好吧，珍娜，我不知道你有没有注意到，当潘和罗伊在谈话时，整场戏的背景音乐一直在播放，然后当罗伊和肯尼开始砸东西时，音乐达到高潮。是的。那是堪萨斯乐队的《Carry On My Wayward Son》，我觉得这是一个很有趣的选择。是的。没错。好吧，大卫·华莱士家的派对也结束了，迈克尔和珍正在开车回家，哦，这段车程。这也许是我最喜欢的场景之一，直到我为了这次重温看它之前，我甚至不知道这是我最喜欢的场景。我对迈克尔和珍百看不厌。他们简直是一团糟，但看他们太有趣了。而且玛洛拉太棒了。你知道，珍说，我觉得恶心。我就是觉得恶心，而他说，你可以吃土豆沙拉，
did you? You can't let that go. She's like, no, I just think it was a mistake to take our relationship public. It was so much more exciting when it was a secret. Michael is so hurt. Michael's like, I want it all, Jan. I want the house and the kids and the picket fences and the ketchup bites and the tickling and the giggling. I know. And then this is when Malora's performance is one of my favorite things. She's like, you know what? I didn't mean it. I didn't mean it. I'm just tired. I didn't mean it, Michael. She's so good. She's so good. She's so good. And then, of course, out of nowhere, Dwight's like, you guys don't break up. You're so good together. I did not remember that he was going to pop up at the end of that scene. It was great. And you know what?
你吃了吗？你不能放着不管。她说，不，我只是觉得把我们的关系公开是个错误。当它是个秘密时要刺激得多。迈克尔伤透了心。迈克尔说，我全都要，珍。我想要房子、孩子、白栅栏、番茄酱咬一口、挠痒痒和咯咯笑。我知道。然后这就是玛洛拉的表演成为我最喜欢的部分之一的时候。她说，你知道吗？我不是那个意思。我不是那个意思。我只是累了。我不是那个意思，迈克尔。她太棒了。她太棒了。她太棒了。然后，当然，毫无征兆地，德怀特说，你们别分手。你们在一起太棒了。我不记得他会突然出现在那场戏的结尾。太棒了。你知道吗？
They don't break up. Michael frames his love contract. That's in a deleted scene. You don't see. You know, he thinks of it as a love contract. He really does. And he frames it. He's so proud of it. It's just a letter to HR. That's all it is. Well, the episode ends with a pretty big cliff hanger. Yeah. And we don't do a ton of cliff hangers on this show, but this is one. Roy is sitting outside in the parking lot of poor Richards. Kenny comes out. He explains that he paid off the bar with the jet ski money so they won't call the cops. And then Roy says, I'm going to kill Jim Helper. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Yeah. This is kind of big for our show, because we never have a button like this. No, no. And we'll get to it next week. But boy,
他们没有分手。迈克尔把他的爱情合同装裱起来了。那是在一个被删减的场景里。你没看到。你知道，他把它当作爱情合同。他真的是这么想的。他把它装裱起来了。他为此感到非常骄傲。那只是一封给人力资源的信。仅此而已。好吧，这一集以一个相当大的悬念结束。是的。我们在这部剧里不常搞悬念，但这是其中一个。罗伊坐在可怜的理查德酒吧外面的停车场里。肯尼出来了。他解释说他用摩托艇的钱把吧台的账清了，这样他们就不会报警了。然后罗伊说，我要杀了吉姆·哈珀。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。是的。这对于我们的节目来说算是一件大事，因为我们从来没有过这样的收尾。不，不。我们下周会讲到。但是天哪，
how we open next week. Yeah. Well, we had a fan catch here in this little scene in the parking lot. Max Beter Wieselberg said, we see a car parked outside of poor Richards with the license plate CHT 8635. We have seen this license plate elsewhere, but it's always associated with Meredith's van. And Creed's Cadillac has this same license plate in the episode gossip. What is the story with this license plate? Oh, what a good catch. You guys are so good. Clearly, it's a license plate we had cleared, and we just kept putting it on different cars. Am I right? Yes. They had a few of these Pennsylvania license plates. And, you know, if we had a scene where a couple characters had to be walking down the street, we would park a couple of cars and just slap these approved
我们下周怎么开场呢。好吧，我们在停车场这个小场景里发现了一个粉丝彩蛋。马克斯·贝特·维瑟尔伯格说，我们看到可怜的理查德酒吧外面停着一辆车，车牌号是 CHT 8635。我们在别处见过这个车牌，但它总是和梅丽迪斯的货车联系在一起。而且在八卦那一集里，克里德的凯迪拉克也有这个车牌。这个车牌有什么故事吗？哦，真是个好发现。你们太厉害了。很显然，这是一个我们备案过的车牌，我们只是不断把它挂在不同的车上。我说的对吗？是的。他们有几个这样的宾夕法尼亚州车牌。而且，你知道，如果我们有一场戏需要几个角色在街上走，我们会停几辆车，然后把这些获批的
license plates on them. And there weren't a ton of them. And so they just went on whatever car was visible. And they were not counting on Max Beter to keep track. They were not, but he did. Well, guys, that was cocktails. We will be back next week with the negotiation and special guest, David Denman. Oh, David Denman's going to be there. Angela Martin might be titillated. Oh, she is. She is. But guys, before we go, Cody is weighing in on that background catch at 16 minutes, 50 seconds. And she says it literally looks like a person with a yellow blanket over them. It is so weird. Wait, can I see it, Cody? Can you put, can you, can you show it to us? What is that? That's so weird. Right? It's super creepy creep. David Wallace's house is haunted.
车牌挂上去。而且数量并不多。所以它们就挂在任何看得见的车上。他们可没指望马克斯·贝特会去留意这个。他们没有，但他真的去留意了。好吧，各位，那是鸡尾酒那一集。我们下周将带着《谈判》一集和特邀嘉宾大卫·丹曼回归。哦，大卫·丹曼要来。安吉拉·马丁可能会被撩拨到。哦，她会的。她会的。但是各位，在我们离开之前，科迪对16分50秒的那个背景彩蛋发表了看法，她说这看起来真的像一个人身上披着黄色毯子。太诡异了。等等，我能看看吗，科迪？你能把它，你能把它展示给我们看吗？那是什么？太诡异了。对吧？超级诡异。大卫·华莱士的房子闹鬼了。
All right. That is the biggest takeaway from today's episode, everyone. But listen, we'll put it all up on Office Ladies Pod. You can decide who this creeper is in the background of Michael's talking head. All right, you guys, we hope you have a great week and we'll see you next week. Love you. Bye, love ya. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧。这是今天这一集最大的收获，各位。但是听着，我们会把它全部发到 Office Ladies 播客上。你可以决定迈克尔单人镜头背景里这个诡异的家伙到底是谁。好了，各位，我们希望你们度过愉快的一周，我们下周见。爱你们。拜拜，爱你们。感谢收听 Office Ladies。Office Ladies 由欧文、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的 Office Ladies，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需一个月的 Stitcher Premium 免费试用，请使用代码 Office。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。